ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDIN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
CHEN. TO CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY. DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEAVE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN APPICE
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA IN. WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON P. THREE
NOR IS WORK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS
RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TAKING
VALIDATORS VIA PULA VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER MISTER COOPER. DEAR LORD
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING TOGETHER
THE BODY OF COMMITTED AND
TALENTED COMMUNITY SERVICE FOR
ONE PURPOSE TO UPLIFT OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE SERVICE
LEADERS OF CHANGE. LOOK TO YOU
LORD TO HELP OF COMBAT POVERTY
TO ELIMINATE THE INJUSTICES OF
THE WORLD IN A CHALLENGE RACISM
AND HATE. THE KEYBOARD TO GUIDE
US AS WE TAKE THIS MONTH. LEARN
ABOUT THE STRUGGLES OUR PEOPLE
HAVE FACED AND HOW WE FACED
ADVERSITY. WE FIND STRENGTH IN
YOU LORD WHEN OUR FATH IS
TESTED AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ETERNAL LOVE. WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO BLESS THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING AND GUIDE US IN OUR
FUTURE ENDEAVORS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GRACE AND ALLOWING US TO
CELEBRATE THE EXTRAORDINARY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN OUR GREAT NATION.
ALL THESE THINGS WE PRAY IN
YOUR NAME AMEN. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MCCARTY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAIRMAN SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY JANUARY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
MEDIT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
JESSE GABRIEL SIMPLY MEMBER
FORTY FIFTH DISTRICT IS ADDING
TO FOLKS WHO PARK AT THE DESK
REFLECTIVITY GOING READING ROLL
CALL THE FOLLOWING A PLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA RARENESS
MOVES. AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVIE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MEMBERS I WOULD
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE FLOOR THE
ASSEMBLY. PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
YOUR SPACING. WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. M. ISRAEL
YES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE TO HAVE A GUEST
SEATED AT HER DESK AND FOR
SIMPLY MEMBER COME LONGER TO
HELP PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AT THE WATER GARCIA
AGUIAR-CURRY. GIPSON ANSWERED
WANT THIS TO SPEAK ON IN GERMAN
IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAN TO
TAKE UP H. R. TWENTY THREE
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADOPTION. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA. THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
MEET ON THURSDAY FEBRUARY
EIGHTEEN. UPON CALL OF THE
CHAIR TO HEAR S. B. ESPYS
EIGHTY FIVE THROUGH EIGHTY
EIGHT AND ESPYS NINETY TWO
THROUGH NINETY FIVE. MS WILDER
FOR WHAT PURPOSE WE WOULD HOLD
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AND ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL MISS WALDRON IS
WITHHOLDING. MS REYES MOVED
SECONDED BY MR BONTA. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL MOTION. A
RULES SUSPENSION TAKES FORTY IN
A SEVENTY NINE MEMBER HOUSE
THIS IS PROCEDURAL MEMBERS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE MS
RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MS RACES ASKING. FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MISS WALDRON AND NOW.
MEMBERS THIS IS PROCEDURAL
TAKES FORTY ON THE ROLLS
SUSPENSION. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL EYES FIFTY KNOWS THIRTEEN.
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. MEMBERS. WE ARE BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE WILL
BE TAKING A FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S.
B. TWENTY NINE. GOD BLESS YOU.
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR- BURKE
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS IN THE CLEARLY
URGENCY THERE ARE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR BERMAN
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB TWENTY NINE
AUTHORED BY SENATOR UMBERG. SB
TWENTY NINE WILL REQUIRE
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO MAIL A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT. TO EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTER FOR
SPECIAL ELECTIONS HELD IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. AND WILL
ALSO REQUIRE COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO USE A VOTE BY MAIL
TRACKING SYSTEM. THAT WILL
ALLOW VOTERS TO TRACK THEIR
BALLOTS. TO PROTECT BOTH VOTERS
AND POLL WORKERS LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED A. B. C. EIGHT SIXTY.
WHICH WAS A SUCCESSFUL STRONGLY
BI PARTISAN EFFORT. THAT APPLY
TO THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION AND REMIND EVERYBODY.
NINE REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR AB
EIGHT SIXTY LAST YEAR. THIS
YEAR SB TWENTY NINE EXTENDS OF
THOSE VOTE BY MAIL RULES FOR
SPECIAL ELECTIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I THINK WE SHOULD
EXTEND THE KEY PROVISIONS OF AB
EIGHT SIXTY PERMANENTLY. AND I
HAVE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
DO SO. I BELIEVE THAT THOSE
CHANGES WILL LEAD TO MORE
INCLUSIVE AND REPRESENTATIVE
ELECTIONS I LOOK FORWARD TO
DEBATE ON THAT BILL LATER THIS
YEAR. SB TWENTY NINE DOES NOT
SEEK TO ENACT LONG TERM-
ELECTIONS POLICY. RATHER THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS NOT GONE AWAY. IT
CONTINUES TO THREATEN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS A RESULT WE
NEED TO ACT QUICKLY TO EXTEND
THE PROTECTIONS AUTHORIZED BY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY FOR
ELECTIONS HELD THIS YEAR. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER AB EIGHT
SIXTY WAS A HUGE SUCCESS WELL
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS THAT
AFFECT TURN OUT IT IS NOTABLE
THAT MORE THAN 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS REGISTERED VOTERS
CAST BALLOTS. IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION THE HIGHEST CALIFORNIA
TURN OUT SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO. WHEN GIVEN THE OPTION THIS
PAST ELECTION NEARLY 87% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS CHOSE TO
VOTE. USING THE BALLOT THAT WAS
MAILED TO THEM PARTICULARLY IN
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL RURAL
COUNTIES WHICH I'VE WRITTEN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SB TWENTY
NINE ALSO ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES THE TWO COUNTIES THAT
CURRENTLY ARE HOLDING SPECIAL
ELECTIONS. TO FILL VACANCIES IN
THE LEGISLATURE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR UMBERG I AFTER I VOTE
ON SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN. DR CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND A COLLEAGUE SAW TODAY I
RISE IN OPPOSITION NOT TO S. B.
TWENTY NINE WHICH REQUIRES SO
EVERY COUNTY- TO SEND EVERY
REGISTERED TO VOTE OR A VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT FOR ANY ELECTION
TWENTY ONE EVEN IF WILL BE
REGISTERED THE BORDER DID NOT
THE REQUESTED A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT AND IT REALLY FOR THE
ART IS OUR NORMAL HEALTH
THOUGHT EMERGENCY. AT THE TIME
OF THE ELECTION. WE WERE TOLD
THIS UNIVERSAL VOLTA BY MAIL
PROCESS WAS UNNECESSARY OF
FORTY AT TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL
ELECTION FOR SAFETY REASONS
DURING THE OF CORBETT NINETY IN
ENDEMIC. HOWEVER WE KNOW IT IS
NOT POSSIBLE TO ADMINISTER IN
PERSON ELECTIONS WHILE
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THE FROM COLD WITH NINETY. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE REDUCTIONS ARE ARE
AUTHORIZED TO FOR YOU SO AND
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
ALTHOUGH MANY MILLIONS OR MORE
NEEDS TO BE- VACCINATED AS SOON
AS A POSSIBLE. SINCE WE ARE
MOVING OUT OF THIS UP AND THAT
MAKE OUT WITH THE VACCINES AND
A WE KNOW WE CAN SAFELY OR FOR
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS ARE TO
THOSE SO WHO REQUEST ONE
WIRELESS SAFETY ALL OFFERING
SUCH IN PERSON VOTING FOR THOSE
SO WHO DO NOT WANNA RECEIVER A
VOTE. BY MAIL BALLOT ARE WILL
BE VOTING AGAINST OUR S. B.
TWENTY NINE TODAY ALSO A LOT OF
A WASTE OF FOR THOSE SO WHO
CHOOSE TO MORE DIRECTLY IN
PERSON AND- MANY BELLOWS ARE
SUBJECT TO BE SENT. TO THOSE TO
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN ALL
HAVE BEEN DEAD OR MOVED UP OUT
OF THERE. ALL CURRENT HOME.
PROTECTING THE INTO OF OUR
ELECTIONS SO IT IS SO ONE OF
THE MOST A SACRED TO
RESPONSIBILITIES SO OR WHAT OUR
GOVERNMENT. ANDERSON SAID SB
TWENTY NINE PROVISO NORTH STATE
GARCIA AGAINST THE VOTER FRAUD
AND- MANDATES DO ARE UNIVERSAL
MAY LOCK THE BALLOT SYSTEM EVEN
IF ALL NORMAL HELD FOR HIM
ADJUSTED EXISTS OF LOCALLY I
RESPECTIVELY BUDGET A NOVOTEL.
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR CHOI. RECOGNIZE SAYING
MR SAY OUR TOE IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY I STAND
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY NINE
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERN FOR
VOTER HEALTH AND SAFETY AND I
OF COURSE SUPPORT ENSURING THAT
EVERY CITIZEN WHO IS ENTITLED
TO VOTE AS EASY ACCESS TO THE
BALLOT BOX TO MAKE THEIR VOICES
HEARD. HOWEVER THIS LEGISLATION
IS SIMPLY NOT NECESSARY. THIS
PAST YEAR WE HAVE ADJUSTED TO
NEW SAFETY STANDARDS AND THE U.
S. CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
CONCLUDED THAT IN PERSON
ELECTIONS. CAN BE SAFELY HELD.
WITH A PROPER APPROPRIATE
PRECAUTIONS. VOTERS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT VOTING AT THE
POLLS ARE FREE TO VOTE BY MAIL.
AS THEY ALWAYS HAVE BEEN. WE
SAW IN THE LAST ELECTION MANY
VOTERS ALSO CHOSE TO PHYSICALLY
GO TO THE POLLS TO HAVE MORE
CONTROL OVER THEIR BALLOT. OR
TO UTILIZE ANY OF THE SPECIAL
SERVICES. AND THAT IS THEIR
RIGHT TO DO SO. WE ALSO OBSERVE
THAT THE EFFORT TO CENTRALIZE
VOTER LOCATIONS RESULTED IN
FEWER LOCAL POLLING LOCATIONS.
AND BECAUSE LONGER LINES AND
INCREASED. IN PERSON CONTACT.
WE STAND HERE AND DISCUSS THE
PUBLIC SAY HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE ELECTION YET THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL HEALTH SAFETY OF
BALLOT HARVESTING AND
INDIVIDUALS GOING DOOR TO DOOR
SOLICITING BORDER BY MAIL
BALLOTS. I TRULY FEEL THAT WE
HAVE THE MEANS AND THE
KNOWLEDGE NECESSARY TO HANDLE
THESE NEXT ELECTIONS WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH. HEALTH IT IS FOR THAT
REASON THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. AND MISTER BENNETT
YOU ALSO ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY NINETEEN SIXTY POINT
NINE MILLION BALLOTS WERE CAST
IN STATEWIDE IN SPECIAL
ELECTIONS IN OREGON. IN THAT
TIME PERIOD THOSE TWENTY YEARS
THERE WERE THIRTY EIGHT
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS OF VOTER
FRAUD. THAT IS LESS THAN A TEN
THOUSANDS OF A PERCENT IN TERMS
OF THE PROBLEM. WE HEAR HERE
OPPOSITION BASED ON INTEGRITY
OF LACKED A LACK SHINS AND
VOTER FRAUD IT SIMPLY IS NOT
BACKED UP BY THE EVIDENCE. THE
EVIDENCE OF A WASHINGTON POST
ANALYSIS FOUND THAT. OF
FOURTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
BALLOTS CAST IN THE FIVE STATES
THAT HAVE ALL ACTION BALLOTS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AT MOST THERE WERE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
POSSIBLE VIOLATIONS AND FINALLY
THE NONPARTISAN AMERICAN
STATISTICAL ASSOCIATION. FOUND
THAT. WASHINGTON WOULD HAVE
REPORTED EIGHTY MORE CASES OF
FRAUD HAD IT NOT INTRODUCED
VOTE BY MAIL THE EVIDENCE
SIMPLY DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
ALLEGATION THAT VOTER FRAUD IS
A REASON WHY WE SHOULD NOT DO
SOMETHING THAT EXPANDS
DEMOCRACY PARTICULARLY EXPANDS
DEMOCRACY FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THE GREATEST DIFFICULTY
GETTING TO THE POLLS AND
VOTING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT MR
MACE YOUR RECOGNIZED I THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS- MEASURE I
SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE IN
COMMITTEE AND THE TRUTH IS-
I'VE BEEN A BIG FAN OF A VOTE
BY MAIL WELL FOR A VERY LONG
TIME I CAN'T THINK OF THE LAST
TIME THAT I WANT. TO VOTE IN
PERSON. WHAT IS SHOCKING TO ME-
IS AT THIS STAGE. OF US EVEN
HAVING THIS DEBATE BECAUSE I
REMEMBER BEING A- YOUNG ISSUE A
REPUBLICAN ACTIVIST. GOING OUT
AND TRYING TO GET MORE PEOPLE
TO VOTE BY MAIL BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT REPUBLICANS WERE IN
TURN OUT. A MORE THE TRUTH IS
THIS IS THE SAFEST. IT CAN BE
VERIFIED. IT'S CHEAPER IT'S
EASIER I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A MEASURE THEY'LL BE COMING FOR
THIS NEXT YEAR THEY'LL MAKE
THIS PERMANENT IN THE FUTURE.
MEMBERS ASK YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER MAYES. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MR BERMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER SO I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ONLY MAKE THESE CHANGES
FOR THE SPECIAL ELECTIONS IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AS ONE
OF REITERATE THAT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY WEAKER THAN THE BILL
THAT THIS BODY PASSED LAST YEAR
WITH A STRONG BIPARTISAN VOTE
INCLUDING NINE OF OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES VOTING
FOR MY BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS
STRONGER. THAN THIS ONE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE HOW MANY
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING ORANGE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE ARE ALREADY VOTERS
CHOICE ACT COUNTIES WHERE THE
VOTERS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
ALREADY GET A BALLOT SENT TO
THEM IN THE MAIL AUTOMATICALLY
WITHOUT REQUESTING ONE ALL THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO IS EXPAND THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE SAFELY AND
SECURELY WITHOUT RISKING THEIR
HEALTH- IN ANY SPECIAL
ELECTIONS THAT OCCUR IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IT WITH%
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN AND WITH THAT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE IS THERE
TO VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
MR BERMAN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS
MEMBERS CAN I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. LEVINE WE WILL NOW
BE MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. WITHOUT OBJECTION. WE
REMOVED THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO ACR EIGHTEEN KAMLAGER FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
THIS KAMLAGER YOU READY TO
PRESENT. THE CLERK WILL READ
ACR EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN
BY SIMPLY MEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. GALLAGHER YOU
CAN OPEN ON THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR EIGHTEEN BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. THE STORY OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH BEGINS IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN HALF A CENTURY
AFTER THE THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT
ABOLISHED SLAVERY IN THE UNITED
STATES. THAT SEPTEMBER THE
HARVARD TRAINED HISTORIAN
CARTER G. WOODSON AND THE
PROMINENT MINISTER JESSE MORLUN
FOUNDED THE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
STUDY OF NEGRO LIFE AND
HISTORY. AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO RESEARCHING AND
PROMOTING ACHIEVEMENTS BY BLACK
AMERICANS AND OTHER PEOPLES OF
AFRICAN DESCENT. THAT GROUP
SPONSORED AND NATIONAL NEGRO
WEEK IN NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
CHOOSING THE SECOND WEEK OF
FEBRUARY TO COINCIDE WITH THE
BIRTHDAYS OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN
AND FREDERICK DOUGLASS. IN THE
DECADES THAT FOLLOWED MAYORS OF
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY BEGAN
ISSUING YEARLY PROCLAMATIONS
RECOGNIZING NEGRO HISTORY WEEK.
BY THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES
THANKS IN PART TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND A GROWING
AWARENESS OF BLACK IDENTITY
NEGRO HISTORY WEEK HAD EVOLVED
INTO BLACK HISTORY MONTH ON
MANY COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
PRESIDENT FORD OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED BLACK HISTORY MONTH
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX CALLING
UPON THE PUBLIC TO SEIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR THE TOO
OFTEN NEGLECTED
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. OF BLACK
AMERICANS IN EVERY AREA OF
ENDEAVOR THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY.
THE BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS NOT
ABOUT ELEVATING THAT ONE BLACK
FRIEND THAT WE ALL HAVE. IT IS
ABOUT HONORING THE RICHNESS
THAT WE ALL EXPERIENCE FROM
BLACK EXISTENCE. AND
RECOGNIZING THAT IT HAS COME AT
AN EXTREME COST. AND IF WE ARE
TO CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY THEN
WE MUST ALL FIGHT FOR BLACK
FUTURES. BLACK FUTURES INVITING
SISTANCE OUR COLLECTIVE FUTURES
WHICH ARE IN PERIL. 73% OF
BLACK PEOPLE. LIVE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGH NUMBERS
OF HEALTH CONDITIONS INCLUDING
DIABETES AND HEART DISEASE
OBESITY AND FOOD AND SECURITY.
BLACK CHILDREN REPRESENT 19% OF
THE NATION'S PRESCHOOL
POPULATION YET 47% OF THOSE
CHILDREN RECEIVE MORE THAN ONE
OUT OF SCHOOL SUSPENSION. 61%
OF ACT TESTED BLACK STUDENTS
AND GRADUATING CLASSES MEET
NONE OF THE FOUR ACT COLLEGE
READINESS BENCHMARKS COMPARED
231% OF WHITE STUDENTS. WHITE
HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUTS. HAVE AN
OWNERSHIP RATE OF 61% COMPARED
WITH 55% PERCENT FOR COLLEGE
GRADUATES WHO ARE BLACK. BLACK
PEOPLE ARE SIX TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE UNEMPLOYED THAN
WHITE AMERICANS. BLACK
AMERICANS HAVE LOWER FIGHT GO
SCORES MORE STUDENT DEBTS A
LARGER AMOUNTS OF HIGH INTEREST
DEBTS. HAVE FEWER ASSETS THAN
WHITE. AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
BE HOMEOWNERS TO OWN THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES WHAT HAVE RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS. BLACK PEOPLE WHO OWN
FIFTY TO SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. ARE EXPOSED TO MUCH
HIGHER LEVELS OF INDUSTRIAL
CHEMICALS AIR POLLUTION AND
POISONOUS HEAVY METALS. THAT
ARE PROFOUNDLY WHITE PEOPLE
WITH ANNUAL INCOMES OF LESS
THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THESE STATISTICS ARE SHAMEFUL
AND INTERCONNECTED. YET DESPITE
THIS DATA. OUR HISTORY REVEALS
ARE RELENTLESS FEARLESSNESS.
AND THIS COUNTRY'S FEAR OF US.
DID YOU KNOW THAT THE EARLIEST
ONE OF THE EARLIEST U. S.
PATENTS GRANTED WAS TO A BLACK
MAN. HOW DO WE KNOW THIS WELL
IN EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE NORBERT
RELU INVENTED AN EVAPORATOR
THAT WAS USED IN SUGAR
PRODUCTION. THE REASON THE
PATENT FILE NOTES HIS RACE IS
BECAUSE SOMEONE TRIED TO TAKE
IT FROM HIM. BECAUSE HE WAS
BLACK. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
PATENTS WERE FILED BY BLACK
PEOPLE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
AND NINETEEN FORTY. WE INVENTED
ALL KINDS OF THINGS THE
ELEVATOR. ROTARY ENGINES A
TAPERED GOLF T. OF FERTILISER
DISTRIBUTOR AND THE PRECURSOR
TO THE GAS MASK. BUT THERE WERE
DIPS IN THOSE INNOVATIONS. ONE
DAY IT WAS IN NINETEEN HUNDRED
WITH PLESSY V. FERGUSON. THE
SUPREME COURT RULING THAT SAID
BLACK PEOPLE WERE SEPARATE BUT
EQUAL. SUDDENLY WE WERE KICKED
OUT OF LIBRARIES COMMERCIAL
DISTRICTS. CUT AWAY FROM
TALKING WITH OTHER INVENTORS.
WE WERE ALSO LYNCHED AND FORCE
TO DEFEND OUR LIVE IN
SEGREGATED AMERICA SCOTLAND
CONCERT. I THINK OF THOSE
HISTORIES. BECAUSE IT HELPS ME
NAVIGATE THE GIVE AND TAKE OF
BEING BLACK IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND SHOULDERING THE BURDEN OF
DEFENDING AND DEFINING BLACK
EXISTENCE. LAST YEAR MY
DAUGHTER WAS SCHOOLS ROOMING
WITH HER CLASS. AND THE TEACHER
SAID YOU KNOW I'M FROM OHIO
WHERE WE DIDN'T KNOW ANY BLACK
PEOPLE. AND NOW I ONLY PREFER
DARK SKINNED PEOPLE. A FEW
YEARS AGO MY HUSBAND WHO'S AN
ATTORNEY. I WAS DROPPING OFF
SOME PAPERWORK AT THE
COURTHOUSE IN BUSINESS CASUAL
AND THE CLERK SURROUNDED BY
STAFF SAID- ARE YOU THE THREE
O'CLOCK SURRENDER. YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
DOING HUMANITARIAN WORK. IN THE
APPALACHIAN MOUNTAINS OF WEST
VIRGINIA WITH MY CLASS THE
PRIEST WHO ORGANIZED THE GROUP
PULLED ME TO THE SIDE AND SAID.
DON'T BE OFFENDED IF SOMEONE
CALLED YOU A **** THEY'VE NEVER
SEEN A BLACK PERSON BEFORE. I
NOW THINK OF THE AUDACITY OF
THAT PRIEST AND I'M CLOSING
MISTER CHAIR. TO PLACE THAT
BURDEN ON A CHILD. TO SHOULDER
A LOAN. RATHER THAN TO THE
GROUP. AND TO USE THE GROUP'S
COLLECTIVE STRENGTH TO COME
BACK EDUCATE AND ADDRESS THAT
KIND OF IGNORANCE. TELLING ME
THAT DIDN'T FIX ANYTHING. IT
JUST SHIFTED HIS ACCOUNTABILITY.
THESE STORIES OLD AND CURRENT
REMIND ME OF HOW WE ARE STILL
ON OUR OWN. LIKE HOW ON WE ON
HOW. YES LIKE IN TULSA IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. WHEN THE
MASSACRE THAT DAY BURNED DOWN
AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF BLACK
PEOPLE. SO I CLOSE BY SAYING IF
YOU SEE SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING.
IF YOU KNOW SOMETHING DO
SOMETHING. I'VE SHARED WITH YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS HISTORY
SO THAT NOW YOU KNOW. AND NOW
YOU MUST DO. IT IS NOT UP TO
ONE BLACK PERSON ON YOUR STREET
IN YOUR CHURCH AT YOUR JOB OR
IN THESE CHAMBERS TO CARRY
THESE BURDENS ALONE. BECAUSE
NOW YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW. AND
NOW THAT WE KNOW WE MUST DO
SOMETHING IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
IN OUR CHURCHES AND OUR
WORKPLACES AND IN THESE
CHAMBERS TO UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORY TO DEFEND THE EXISTENCE
AND TO SUPPORT THE FUTURE. OF
BLACK PEOPLE. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE MR MEDINA
FROM THE REAR THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR EIGHTEEN. ACR
EIGHTEEN WILL RECOGNIZE
FEBRUARY. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THISBLACK HISTORY MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE BLACK HISTORY IS
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. WITHOUT THE
SOCIAL EDUCATIONAL SCIENTIFIC
AND SEVERAL OTHER CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY OUR STATE WOULD
SIMPLY NOT BE WHERE IT IS TODAY.
FROM FEARS LEADERS LIKE OUR OWN
DOCTOR SHIRLEY WEBER.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST BLACK
SECRETARY OF STATE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILLIE BROWN AND
CONGRESS MEMBER KAREN BASS THE
FIRST BLACK MEN AND WOMEN
SERVICE SPEAKERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY RESPECTIVELY. AND
CALIFORNIA'S OWN CAMERA HERE'S
OUR FIRST BLACK AND ASIAN
AMERICAN VICE PRESIDENT. THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS
GIVEN US EXCEPTIONAL STATE WIDE
AND NATIONAL LEADERS. HOWEVER
WE WOULD BE REMISS IF WE DID
NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE PAINFUL
HISTORY. THE BLACK COMMUNITY
HAS AND DIVERT FROM ITS
INCEPTION OF THIS COUNTRY TO
THIS DAY. SLAVERY VOTER
SUPPRESSION POLICE BRUTALITY
AND MORE CONTINUE TO
SYSTEMATICALLY SHAPE THE
EXPERIENCES OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS EVERYWHERE. WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING THIS HISTORY WE
CANNOT CORRECTIVE THAT IS WHY
TEACHING THIS IS ST BEYOND
FEBRUARY IS CRITICAL AND WHY
THE LATINO CAUCUS HAS
PRIORITIZED ETHNIC STUDIES FOR
ALL IN RECENT YEARS. THIS PAST
YEAR ALONE HAS REMINDED US ALL
THE WORK STILL LEFT TO BE DONE.
AND HOW WE MUST ALWAYS STRIVE
TO BE BETTER ALLIES AND UP LIVE
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE TO BOTH CELEBRATE THE
TALENTS AND ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY AND RECOMMIT TO
WORKING TOWARDS A MORE JUST
STATE. AND NATION. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA WE WILL NOW RECOGNIZE
MISTER BLOOM FROM THE REAR OF
THE TRAIN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R. EIGHTEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS. BLACK HISTORY
MONTH HELPS US CHARTER FUTURE
BY ASKING US TO REFLECT ON THE
LESSONS OF THE PAST. IT
ENHANCES OUR APPRECIATION OF
THE WIDE RANGING CONTRIBUTIONS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN SCIENCE
MUSIC LITERATURE AND AS WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE MEMBER FROM LOS
ANGELES A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
ENDEAVORS. THIS MONTH ALSO
CALLED ENOUGH TO USE THE
LESSONS OF HISTORY SO THAT WE
CAN IDENTIFY AND EMPATHIZE WITH
THE BLACK COMMUNITY. JUST AS
UNDERSTANDING THE HOLOCAUST
HELPS GENTILES TO UNDERSTAND
JEWS. SO IT IS THAT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND EVERYONE. I KNOW
THE HISTORY OF SLAVERY AND
OPPRESSION AND SO MUCH MORE IN
ORDER TO UNDERSTAND JUST WHY
BLACK LIVES MATTER. HISTORY
SHOWS US WHERE ARE COMMON
THREADS ARE AND COMMON THREADS
CAN LEAD TO COMMON
UNDERSTANDING. BLACKS AND JEWS
SHARE EXPERIENCES RANGING FROM
SLAVERY TO EXILE DISCRIMINATION
AND BEING SUBJECTED TO HATE TO
ACTS OF HATE AND INTOLERANCE.
HISTORY CAN BE QUITE PERSONAL
TO. FOR EXAMPLE THE MEMBER FROM
PASADENA AND I. ARE THE SAME
AGE AND GREW UP IN THE SAME
TOWN. BUT AS THE AS CHILDREN
ARE PATHS WOULD LIKELY NOT
CROSS BECAUSE THE CITY OF
PASADENA AND THE SCHOOLS OF
PASADENA WERE DE FACTO
SEGREGATED AT THAT TIME. AS A
YOUNG CHILD I REMEMBER THE DAWN
OF FAIR HOUSING LAWS AND I
VIVIDLY REMEMBER THE TALK AT
THE DINNER TABLE ONE NIGHT. A
BRICK IT CRASHED THROUGH THE
FRONT WINDOW OF ONE OF THE
FIRST FAMILIES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE LAWS. IN THE
DEED RESTRICTED ALL WHITE AND
CLAVE OF NEARBY HASTINGS RANCH.
HAVE THINGS IMPROVED YES BY
SOME METRICS AND NO BY OTHERS.
IT'S A SAD COMMENTARY THAT
TODAY BLACKS AND JEWS SUFFER
FROM THE HIGHEST RATES OF HATE
SPEECH AND CRIMES OR THAT SO
MANY BLACK LIVES ARE LOST IN
ENCOUNTERS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
SO OUR HISTORIES. OUR STORIES
HELP TO GUIDE US FORWARD AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE EACH OF
US INDIVIDUALLY AND
COLLECTIVELY TO USE THIS MONTH
TO REFLECT ON THE AMAZING
HISTORY OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
BLACK HISTORY LIKE JEWISH
HISTORY IS A RICH TAPESTRY. AND
FOR EACH OF US THERE IS MUCH TO
CELEBRATE. YET ALSO SO MUCH
THAT IS DISTRESSING. WE SHOULD
ENDEAVOR TO USE THAT HISTORY TO
HELP US AS DR KING SO
ELOQUENTLY PUT IT. TO BEND THE
LONG ARC OF THE MORAL UNIVERSE
TOWARDS JUSTICE. ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS I
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
LOS ANGELES AND THE BLACK
CAUCUS FOR OFFERING IN
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
THIS WORKS TO RECOGNIZE AND
REJECT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO SUPPORT ACR
EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. BLACK HISTORY
MONTH IS A TIME TO CELEBRATE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT BLACK
WOMEN HAVE MADE TO OUR COUNTRY.
IN THIS RECOGNITION OF YOUR
HISTORY IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXULTS. THE WORK
OF BLACK WOMEN WHO CONTINUE TO
BREAK. BARRIERS ERECTED BY
SOCIETY THE CONSISTENTLY FAILS
TO FULLY VALUED THEM. DESPITE
THE SOCIETAL FAILURES BLACK
WOMEN HAVE BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT. OF EVERY MOVEMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY. FROM ABOLITION TO
RECONSTRUCTION TO WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE AND VOTING RIGHTS.
FROM WOMEN'S RIGHTS EQUAL PAY
TO CIVIL RIGHTS AND LGBTQ LGBTQ
RIGHTS. FROM SOCIETAL JUSTICE
TO RACIAL JUSTICE TO CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND POLICE REFORM JUST
TO NAME A FEW. AT EVERY FIVE
BLACK WOMEN HAVE SHOWN UP FOR
THIS NATION AND TAKING MORE OF
THE HEADS AND SACRIFICED MORE
THAN MANY OF US WILL EVER KNOW
OR UNDERSTAND. THEIR WORK IS
OFTEN GIVEN THE REST OF US A
BLUEPRINT FOR CHANGE WHETHER
THEY CHOSE. TO BE LEADERS. OR
THE LEADERSHIP WAS FORCED UPON
THEM OUT OF NECESSITY. OR
SURVIVAL. THE UGLY TRUTH THAT
WE SHOULD ALL SET WITH HOWEVER
IS THAT BLACK WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE YET TO RECEIVE.
THE EQUITY THEY DESERVE THE
JUSTICE THEY ARE OWED OR THE
PLACE OF THE TABLE POWER THEY
HAVE BURNED. WITH EVERY SUCCESS
STORY. AND BARRIER BREAKING
HIGHLIGHTED IN A C. R. EIGHTEEN
THERE ARE STILL MILLIONS OF
BLACK WOMEN WHO FACE A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
DISPARITIES IN PAY. HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND HOUSING ACCESS.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
EMPLOYMENT DATA FROM DECEMBER
SHOWS THAT WOMEN BORE THE BRUNT
OF THE JOB LOSS BUT ALARMINGLY
THAT BURDEN IS FALLING SQUARELY
ON THE SHOULDERS OF WOMEN OF
COLOR. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
LOST EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND JOBS
DURING THE MONTH OF DECEMBER.
DURING THAT SAME PERIOD WHAT
WOMEN ACTUALLY GAINED JOBS. AND
THE BLACK WOMEN WHO ARE STILL
IN THE WORK FORCE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WORK IN SOME
OF THE HARDEST HIT SECTORS OF
THE PANDEMIC. OFTEN ROLES
LACKING PAID SICK LEAVE AND THE
ABILITY TO WORK FROM HOME. THAT
IS PART OF THE REASON THEY ARE
37% MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
COVERED NINETEEN COMPARED TO
THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS. AND
IRONICALLY ENOUGH IT IS A BLACK
WOMAN. DR COMMITTEE CORBETT.
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR CREATING
THE VACCINE THAT WILL HELP AND
THIS PANDEMIC. FOR ALL OF US.
AS LEGISLATORS WE HAVE WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE EGREGIOUS
DISPARITIES AND OTHER
INEQUITABLE REALITIES THAT
IMPACT BLACK WOMEN BY PASSING
LAWS THAT HELP PROTECT WORKING
FAMILIES. THESE INCLUDE
EXTENDING PARENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE HEALTH
CARE THE MATERNAL CARE. IT ALSO
INCLUDES RELIEVING THE BURDEN
OF THE PANDEMIC WITH ITS
INCREASED TESTING IMPACTING
DISTRIBUTION AND ECONOMIC
SUPPORT FOR THE WOMEN WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR HEALTH
SECURITY OUR ECONOMY ON THEIR
SHOULDERS OF THE CENTRAL
WORKERS. INCLUDING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS GROCERY STORE WORKERS
AND RETAIL WORKERS CAN SAFELY
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WE
SHOULDN'T BE SHOCKED BY THE
CONDITIONS THAT ALLOWED THE
PANDEMIC TO RAVAGE THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. THEY EXISTED BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPACT.
THAT CENTURIES OF STRUCTURAL
RACISM AND STATE SANCTIONED
DISCRIMINATION AND VIOLENCE
HAVE HAD. ON THE BLACK
COMMUNITY IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IN CALIFORNIA. ONCE WE DO THAT
WE CAN ACCEPT OUR ROLE IN
RECTIFYING THE CONSEQUENCES AND
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
OTHER BLACK COMMUNITY LEADERS
TO TEAR DOWN. THE SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS THAT CONTINUE TO LIMIT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BLACK
CALIFORNIANS TO THRIVE IN THE
STATE. LET'S START TODAY BY
SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION THAT
CELEBRATES BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
I COMMIT TO WORKING TOGETHER
FOR GOING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. ON BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON IT.
VETERANS WORKS OF THIS. WERE T
ADDRESS. THANK YOU MISTRESS IN
MY ARE TODAY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA L. G. CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A C. EIGHTEEN I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FORD.
MEMBERS LET US BE CLEAR BLACK
HISTORY IS AMERICAN HISTORY
BLACK HISTORY IS CLEAR HISTORY
BLACK HISTORY MONTH IS A
CELEBRATION OF BLACK LIVES IN
THE COUNTLESS COUNTLESS
CONTRIBUTIONS. THAT THERE HAD
ON OUR GREAT COUNTRY. THEIR
INVENTION HAS PUSHED THE
BOUNDARIES OF AMERICAN
INNOVATION THEIR BRAVERY IN
COMBAT TO DEFEND OUR FREEDOMS
WE HOLD SO DEAR AND THEIR
PERSISTENCE IN THE FACE OF
CONTINUED HOSTILITY HAS PAVE
THE WAY. FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
ESSENTIAL CIVIL RIGHTS. IN THE
SPIRIT OF INTERSECTION MALADY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THREE
IMPORTANT BLACK AMERICANS. IN
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY WHO I MADE
IMMENSE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
AMERICA. BAYARD RUSTIN WAS ONE
OF THE LEADERS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. HE WORKED
TOGETHER WITH MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR WITH PHILIP
RANDOLPH AND ELLA BAKER HE
HELPED ORGANIZE THE MONTGOMERY
BOYCOTT. HE ALSO HELPED
ORGANIZE FREEDOM WRITES IN THE
MARCH ON WASHINGTON. A GAY MAN
RUSTIN BECAME A VOCAL ADVOCATE
FOR GAY RIGHTS IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES A MOVE WHICH WAS
ESPECIALLY COURAGEOUS I'VE THAT
WAS THE TIME WHEN LGBTQ RIGHTS
WERE ACTIVELY OPPOSED BY MUCH
OF AMERICAN SOCIETY. ERNESTINE
EXISTING EARNEST TIME ASKING
WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
NEW YORK CHAPTER OF THE
DAUGHTERS ABILITY THE FIRST
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ADVOCATING FOR
LESBIAN RIGHTS. SHE WAS THE
VETERANS AND CIVIL RIGHTS. SHE
ALSO BROUGHT HER EXPERIENCE
FROM THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
TO CALL FOR EQUALITY IN THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY SHE
PARTICIPATED IN THE REMINDER
DAYS MARCHES WHERE SHE WAS THE
ONLY PERSON OF COLOR AND OFTEN
TIMES THE ONLY WOMAN. TO BE
PART OF THE REMINDER DAY
DEMONSTRATIONS IN FRONT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE IN. NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. JAMES BALDWIN FAMOUS FOR
HIS WORK AS AN AUTHOR AND A
PLAY RIGHT MANY OF HIS WORK
EXPLORING THE INNER SEXUALITY
OF ETHNICITY SEXUALITY AND
CLASS IN UNITED STATES HE WAS
ALSO ACTIVE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT HE BECAME ACQUAINTED
WITH THE MOVEMENT AFTER
REPORTING ON IT FROM THE NEW
YORKER THE HARPER HARPER'S AND
THE NEW YORK TIMES MAGAZINE.
WALDRON JOINED THE CONGRESS OF
RACIAL EQUALITY. HE TRAVELED
THE COUNTRY DELIVERING LECTURES
ON RACIAL INEQUALITY AND CALLED
ON PRESIDENT JOHN F. KENNEDY TO
TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. ALONG WITH BAYARD
RUSTIN BALDWIN WAS AMONG THE
GAY MEN INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT SEVERAL OF HIS
NOVELS. INCLUDED OPENLY GAY
CHARACTERS AND RELATIONSHIPS.
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ CAUCUS
REMAIN TOGETHER IN SOLIDARITY
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
BLACK CAUCUS WE JOIN THEM. AND
BEING COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOWARDS REALIZING OURSHARED
DREAMS FOR A BETTER TOMORROW
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A C. R.
EIGHTEEN. CERVANTES IS THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OR DEBATE.
ON THIS MATTER. SENATE HEARING
NONE HAS COME UNDER YOUR
CLOTHES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ALL OF THE
CAUCUSES. FROM ACROSS THE STATE
FOR SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF A C.
R. EIGHTEEN. YOU KNOW I BRIEFLY
MENTIONED NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
IT WAS THE YEAR OF ONE OF THE
MOST WORST WORST INCIDENTS OF
RACIAL VIOLENCE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY IT WAS THE TULSA RACE
MASSACRE. WHERE BLACK PEOPLE
WERE KILLED ON SIGHT. AND IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD AND BLACK
AFFLUENCE AND EXISTENCE WAS
LITERALLY BURNED TO THE GROUND.
NO ONE CAME TO HELP THEM. AT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT NOT THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. NOT EVEN THE
FEDS. NO ONE MATT TOLD BLACK
PEOPLE THAT WE WERE ON OUR OWN.
YET STILL WE'VE HAD AN
UNBRIDLED NEED AND DESIRE TO
CREATE- WHETHER THROUGH
ARCHITECTURE SPORTS AKADEMI OF
THE LAW. THE CREATIVE ARTS SO I
JUST ASK YOU WHEN YOU STOP AT A
TRAFFIC LIGHT OR PULL OUT AN
IRONING BOARD. THINK OF BLACK
INNOVATION WHEN YOU TURN ON
YOUR HOME SECURITY SYSTEM OR
ADMIRE A TESLA S. MODEL. THAT'S
BLACK BRILLIANCE WHEN YOU RIDE
A BIKE OR CONSIDER CATARACT
TREATMENT THAT IS BLACK
INNOVATION. MAYBE BECAUSE OF
THOSE STATISTICS IN THE HISTORY
THAT I SHARED NOW YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW I THINK OF THAT HISTORY I
THINK OF THAT HISTORY THAT I
SHARED EARLIER EVERY DAY IT
HELPS ME NAVIGATE THE GIVE AND
TAKE OF BEING BLACK. AND
INFORMS THE WORK OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND OUR PUSH FOR
POLICIES. THAT TAKE THE BURDEN
OF DEFENDING AND DEFINING BLACK
EXISTENCE FROM OUR SHOULDERS
ALONE. TO THIS CHAMBER AND THE
STATE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. I ONCE AGAIN WANT TO
THANK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON A C.
R. EIGHTEEN I WOULD ALSO ASK
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
A CO AUTHOR. TO ALL THE BIG
AMAZON ORDERS ALL THE BAY
HAVING SEIZED WE WILL MOVE TO A
VOTE ON TE MEASURE. THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN. FOR CO AUTHORS ON
ACR EIGHTEEN. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FOR
PARTNERS MEMBERS. YEAH. THIS
ORDER. SIXTY SEVEN. MEMBERS ARE
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED.
WE CAN NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. THE POEMS NO THE I.
SEVEN THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS YOU'LL RECOGNIZE OUR
UNSUNG HEROES DURING A SPECIAL
EVENT. THAT WILL BE HELD
VIRTUALLY ON FEBRUARY THE
TWENTY THIRD RECOGNITION OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THERE'S A WAY
TO END BLACK HISTORY MONTH ON A
POSITIVE NOTE. MEMBERS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS SELECTED TWO ITEMS TO
SHARE WITH YOU THIS EAR. MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WALL CALENDAR
TITLED BLACK HISTORY FROM
SLAVERY TO THE WHITE HOUSE
FEATURES BLACK PEOPLE WHO HAVE
STATE OUR NATION IN AMERICA
WINS. THE SECOND ITEM IS A BOOK
THAT HAS NOT YET ARRIVED. IT IS
THE MISEDUCATION OF THE NEGRO
MY DOCTOR CARTER WOODSON G.
WHAT'S AND IT WAS FIRST
PUBLISHED IN NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE. DR WATSON WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEGRO HISTORY
WEEK. AS THE SECOND WEEK OF
FEBRUARY ANNUALLY. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN THE GIRL HISTORY WEEK
WAS EXPANDED TO DESIGNATE ALL
OF FEBRUARY AS NEGRO HISTORY OR
BLACK HISTORY MONTH. WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO VIEW THE C. O. B. C.
WEBSITE WHERE WE FEATURE
LANDMARKS IN CALIFORNIA. NAMED
AFTER AFRICAN AMERICANS. THE
WEBSITE ADDRESS IS BLACK CAUCUS
DOT LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE DOT
CA DOT GOV. SELECT MEDIA AND
THEN PHOTOS TO VIEW THE
LANDMARKS DISPLAY. I LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION- THIS MORNING THIS
CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. H. R. TWENTY
THREE BY MR LOW. THE CORKERY
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER LOW AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO HATE CRIMES. MR LOW
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. TO
UNFORTUNATELY BRING FORTH A
RESOLUTION THAT MIGHT SEEM. TO
THE CONTRARY THE UNFORTUNATE
RECOGNITION OF INCREASED HATE
CRIMES TOWARDS MEMBERS OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. BUT WE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT ASIAN AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE. WITHOUT RECOGNIZING
THE SOLIDARITY AND THE ALLY
SHIP OF OUR BLACK BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. THE UNCANNY PARALLEL.
THAT WE AS A COMMUNITY RIDE ON
THE SHOULDERS STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THOSE HAVE COME
BEFORE US. BUT IF WE FORGET OUR
HISTORY. WE'LL SEE IT REPEAT
ITSELF. THAT'S WHY WE NEED
DEMAND ETHNIC STUDIES. THAT'S
WHY WE NEED TO SEE ASIA
PROVIDERS IN THE BOARD'S OF
CORPORATE AMERICA. THAT'S WHY
WE NEED YOUR ALLY SHIP TO SPEAK
IN SOLIDARITY. COLLEAGUES I
STAND. WE SIGNIFICAN ANGUISH.
AS I SPOKE ON THIS FLOOR WITH
RESPECT TO CELEBRATING THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR. AND BRING IN A
NEW PROSPEROUS YEAR. WE SAW A
NUMBER OF ENTRIES TAKE CRIMES
ON THE STREETS OF CALIFORNIA.
YOUR HEAR FROM SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES. ABOUT THE
DISTASTEFUL NATURE THAT WE
STILL SEE TODAY. I'M HURT. I'M
IN PAIN. AS I GATHERED WITH MY
NINETY TWO YEAR YOUNG
GRANDMOTHER FOR LUNAR NEW YEAR
DINNER. PLAYING MAHJONG. SHE
HOLD ME THAT SHE WAS AFRAID TO
DIE. SHE WAS AFRAID TO DIE
BECAUSE SHE WOULD NEED TO GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE. AND ASKED
HER. WHAT DO YOU MEAN ARE YOU
AFRAID OF GETTING HOPE IT. HE
SAID NO I'M AFRAID OF A HATE
CRIME DYING FROM A HATE CRIMES
LAW GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE.
JUST LIKE. MANY OF MY MOTHER'S
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. AND IF
THAT WASN'T A WAKE UP CALL. HE
THEN SAID I WANT YOU IN
GOVERNMENT AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED
TO HELP. WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
PROTECT ME. MY OWN GRANDMOTHER.
ASKING ME. WHAT AM I DOING.
WHAT I LEAVE HOME EACH AND
EVERY DAY TO COME HERE.
COLLEAGUES YOUR HEAR FROM
OTHERS ABOUT THE HORRIFIC
EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YES WE ARE DEALING
WITH A VIRUS. OF RACISM. AND I
HOPE WE'LL USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALLY SHIP.
MEMBERS OF OUR API COMMUNITY
HAVE MARCHED DURING BLACK LIVES
MATTER WE'VE BEEN THERE WITH
YOU. WILL BE THERE ON THE
FARMER'S RIGHTS MOVEMENT WE'RE
THERE WITH YOU WE'RE MARCHING
WITH YOU DURING PRIDE WILL
MARCH WITH YOU. WALMART'S
DURING WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH WE
WILL MARCH WITH YOU. NOW WE'RE
ASKING YOU STAND WITH US MARCH
WITH US SEE US HEAR US. WE'RE
IN DEEP AGONY. YOU MAY NOT SEE
MANY OF US BEING ANDREAS AS
VOCAL AS I AM. BECAUSE THERE'S
THIS PERCEPTION A MODEL
MINORITY THAT WILL JUST DO OUR
JOB WILL KEEP TO OURSELVES KEEP
QUIET. BEDIENT BUT ALLOW ME.
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE PAIN BECAUSE I DO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO SPEAK OUT. UNLIKE
SO MANY OTHERS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY THREE AND
TO LISTEN TO OTHER COLLEAGUES
AS THEY SPEAK AN ALLY SHIP AS
WE ANSWER THIS COLLECTIVE
QUESTION. WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA FOR US ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW. MISTER DAVID CHIU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES NOT
LONG AGO. BUT TIME MANAGEMENT
RATED TO REINSTATE A CALIFORNIA.
HIS DAUGHTER HAD RECENTLY HAD
CHILDREN HE CAME TO LIVE WITH
HER TO TAKE CARE OF HIS
GRANDKIDS. HE WAS EIGHTY FOUR
YEARS OLD. A GENTLE MAN DEEPLY
BELOVED BY FAMILY HE WAS NEARLY
BLIND AND RECENTLY RECOVERING
BY HEART SURGERY. AT EIGHT
THIRTY AM ON JANUARY THE TWENTY
EIGHTH. FEATURE RETURN A PARTY
WAS VIOLENTLY ATTACKED IN A
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD AND
MURDERED ON A QUIET STREET IN
MY CITY. BECAUSE OF THIS MURDER
THE THAI GOVERNMENT HAS TOLD
THAI NATIONALS IN THE UNITED
STATES TO BE WHERE. OF HATE
CRIMES IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS ONE OF THREE SENSELESS
ATTACKS OF ASIAN SENIORS IN
RECENT DAYS. PART OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED DOCUMENTED HATE
INCIDENTS IN THE BAY AREA THIS
PAST YEAR. PART OF ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND REPORTS OF HATE
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS IN OUR
COUNTRY. AND ALL INDICATIONS
ARE THESE STATISTICS ARE THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG. WHAT'S YOUR
API CAUCUS ASKED FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESSES HEY. ASK FOR THE
CREATION OF A RACIAL BIAS TASK
FORCE A STRIKE TEAM OF
CULTURALLY COMPETENT ADVOCATES
ASK FOR FUNDING FOR THESE
EFFORTS. THESE REQUESTS ARE
STILL PENDING. ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SOUTH BAY
WE'RE RE INTRODUCING A BILL TO
ESTABLISH A HATE CRIME HOTLINE
THAT STALLED IN THIS BODY
BEFORE. FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE NOT
ENOUGH. WE NEED ACTION I WANNA
CLOSE BY APPRECIATING THE ALLY
SHIP THAT'S BEEN COMMUNICATED
TO OUR COMMUNITY DURING THESE
TIMES BY MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I
DON'T THINK IT'S A COINCIDENCE
THAT WE CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. AND CONDEMN ANTI ASIAN
HATE. DURING THE SAME SESSION
OUR STRUGGLES ARE INDEED LINKED
AND WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
ANSWERABLE. THANK YOU MR CHIU
MR BONTA S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE.
THIS RESOLUTION COMES AT AN
OPPORTUNE TIME LAST WEEK WE SAW
THE BEGINNING OF THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR A TIME FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES TO COME TOGETHER TO
REFLECT ON THE PAST AND PAY
RESPECT. TO CHURCH ELDERS AND
ANCESTORS. HOWEVER REMEMBERING
THE STRUGGLES THAT ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS HAVE ENDURED
IN IMMIGRATING TO THE UNITED
STATES IS NOT AN EXERCISE THAT
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THE NEW
LUNAR NEW YEAR. OR TWO
INDIVIDUALS OF THE API DESCENT
IT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL DO
AS WE SHAPE A MORE INCLUSIVE
DEFINITION OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE AN AMERICAN. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE NOW WELL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY OUR API COMMUNITY
ENDERS DISCRIMINATION BULLYING
AND HARASSMENT. FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP USING OFFENSIVE
ETHNICALLY BASED TERMS TO
DESCRIBE HOLDEN NINETEEN FIELD
BIGOTRY AND VIOLENT ATTACKS
AGAINST OUR API COMMUNITY. THIS
INCREASE IN ANTI API RHETORIC
HAS RESULTED IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY BEING ASSAULTED AND
SCAPEGOATED FOR THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. JUST IN
RECENT WEEKS THERE HAD BEEN A
SLEW OF VIOLENT ATTACKS ON OUR
API COMMUNITY. A NINETY ONE
YEAR OLD ASIAN AMERICAN MAN WAS
ATTACKED IN OAKLAND. EIGHTY
FOUR YEAR OLD HIGH AMERICAN MAN
WAS KILLED IN SAN FRANCISCO A
SIXTY YEAR OVER SIXTY FOUR YEAR
OLD VIETNAMESE AMERICAN WOMAN
WAS ASSAULTED IN SAN JOSE. A
FILIPINO AMERICAN MAN WAS
SLASHED IN THE FACE IN
MANHATTAN WE MUST COME TOGETHER
AND UNITE AGAINST HATE. AND
VIOLENCE THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
STANDS IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
API CAUCUS TO DENOUNCE THAT
HATEFUL RHETORIC AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST MEMBERS OF OUR API
COMMUNITY WE MUST ALL BRING THE
SPIRIT OF THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES AND WORK
TO END HATE CRIMES AGAINST API
COMMUNITY. MEMBERS NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE MUST STAND
TOGETHER. I STOOD BY. FOR YOUR
VOTE ON HR TWENTY THREE. THANK
YOU MR BONTA S. MISTER RAMOS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
CAUCUS. I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY THREE. HR TWENTY
THREE DENOUNCES THE RISE OF
HATE CRIMES AND INTIMIDATION
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. LATINOS AND NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE ALSO SUFFERED
FROM HATE CRIMES AND
DISCRIMINATION AND MANY TIMES
WE FELT ALONE. BUT TODAY WE
JOIN WITH OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS TO SAY YOUARE NOT
ALONEWE STAND TOGETHER AS ONE
WITH THIS BODY TO STAND SIDE BY
SIDE WITH YOU IN THIS TIME OF
TURMOIL. IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS
WE HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
VIOLENCE COMMITTED AGAINST
OLDER ASIAN AMERICANS WHEN THE
ELDERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING ATTACKED BASED ON THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN WE CANNOT
STAND BACK AND LET PEOPLE FEEL
ALONE IT'S TIME THAT WE COME
TOGETHER WE COME TOGETHER AND
STAND AGAINSTTHESE MORALLY
REPREHENSIBLE CRIMES AND URGED
JUSTICE FOR THE VICTIMS OF
THESE CRIMES. I RISE TO SHOW
SOLIDARITY THAT NO ONE STANDS
ALONE TODAY WE STAND UNITED IN
THE FACE OF HATE CRIMES IN
INTIMIDATION BASED ON ETHNICITY
I URGE OUR VOTE AND WE STAND
UNITED IN THE FACE OF THESE
ISSUES IN FRONT OF US TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS MR BLOOM IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF H. R. TWENTY THREE
WE MUST NOT IGNORE THE
DISTURBING UPTICK IN HATE
CRIMES TARGETED TOWARD. AND
PERPETRATED AGAINST THE AAPI
COMMUNITY. AND AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE STATE OF HATE. I WOULD
LIKE TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THE- DRAMATIC INCREASES
THAT WE'RE SEEING AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
CAL STATE SAMPOERNA DINO CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM IN TWENTY TWENTY
DENVER AND SAN DIEGO SAW THEIR-
FIRST REPORTED. EIGHTY I HATE
CRIMES THAT HAVE BEEN REPORTED
IN YEARS. PHILADELPHIA SAW
THREE FOLD INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF AP I HATE CRIMES. IN
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
EXCUSE ME SAN JOSE. SAW THEIR
API HATE CRIME NUMBERS DOUBLE.
NEW YORK IS SEEING A NINE FOLD
INCREASE IN THESE CRIMES.
MEMBERS IF WE ARE TO REDUCE
HATE SPEECH AND CRIMES. WITH MY
SHINE A LIGHT ON THEM AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DO HERE TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
DR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU A SPEAKER AND A COLLEAGUE
SO. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY KHALEDA. EVAN LOW TO
BRING UP THIS ARE IMPORTANT NOT
A CHILD TWENTY THREE YES I HATE
CRYING. LAST FRIDAY WHEN I WENT
HOME- I ADORED SON TOLD ME. DAD
BE CAREFUL- SO HATE CRIME
AGAINST ASIANS ARE RISING. I
WAS SO. LUCKY ENOUGH FOR NOT TO
BE WITH HIM. IF I HAPPEN TO BE
WITH HIM. AT THE RESTAURANT TO
PICK UP THE FOOD I WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE SAME TARGET OF THE
HATE CRIME. SOMEONE WAS YELLING
AT HIM AND OF COURSE FIRST.
WITH A KIND OF A LANGUAGE OF
THAT I'M GONNA REPEAT HERE. AM
I GUILTY JUST BECAUSE OF MY
LOOK IN THE NATION. ARE YOU A
TARGET OF OUR HATE CRIME JUST
BECAUSE OF YOUR SKIN COLOR AND
THE WAY YOU LOOK AND WHAT KIND
OF ALL RACIAL GROUP ARE YOU MAY
BELONG TO. THE NEXT MORNING THE
KOREA DALY. NOT SURPRISINGLY
HAD A FRONT PAGE. LOOK LORD.
HEY CRIME ORGANIZATIONS ARE
RISING BE CAREFUL. BUSTO FRONT
PAGE ARTICLE. THIS IS SAW
RISING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
BUT CALIFORNIA IS A GREAT WAY
FOR ASIAN IMMIGRANTS ARE TO
ARRIVE FIRST. CAN YOU BELIEVE
THAT- WE CALIFORNIA SO SHOULD
BE MORE TOLERANT. TO ASIAN
POPULATION BUT THE STATISTICS
SHOW THAT THE- ABOUT 40% OF
ENTIRE COUNTRIES I HATE CRIME
THAT'S PLACE A IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS AMERICA LEARNED A HOLD WILL
GET ALONG. AND DELIVER
HARMONIOUSLY IN PEACE AMONG US.
THE UNIQUENESS AND- BEAUTY OF
THIS COUNTRY IS OF BEING A
NATION OF- OUR NATION MADE UP
ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT ALL
IMMIGRANTS ARE FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD. HOW LONG DO WE HAVE
TO. HATE EACH OTHER AND DISLIKE
EACH OTHER TO JUST BECAUSE OF
LAW LOOK R. AND AW. SKIN COLOR.
TODAY WE ARE CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. THIS OUR
HISTORICAL MATERIAL THAT YOU
SEE ON YOUR DESK JUST A FROM US
TO LABOR READY TO THE WHITE
HOUSE. IF. PRESIDENT OBAMA SO
SKIN COLOR MATTER. IN THE BLACK.
REYES THERE'S A DEFINITELY
MINORITY. HE- OR NOT BEEN NOT.
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET THAT ELECTED.
BUT AMERICA. ELECTED HIM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHERE IN THE COUNTRY. WE ARE
MINORITY. WOULD YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO GET ELECTED
THE PRESIDENT OF THAT COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE STRENGTH OF AMERICA
WE HAVE LEARNED A LONG TIME
OVER CIVILIAN RIGHTS MOVEMENTS.
AND ALL THE STRUGGLES ABOUT BUT
WE ARE STILL IS EXPERIENCING. I
THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH. WHAT CAN WE DO AS A
MEMBERS ALL OF THIS TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS NOT RESONATOR.
JUST ALL PASSED A RESOLUTION OF
ABOUT WE HAD A BODY. I'LL
DESTROY ME OR- EACH OF YOU GO
HOME BETTER DISTRICT. MADE A
STATEMENT SO YOUR DOCTOR
NEWSOME. OR WHATEVER COME.
FORMS THAT THAT THIS TYPE OF
LAW HEY CRIME FOR ANY ETHNIC
GROUP BUT DOESN'T MATTER.
NUSTAR ONLY ASIAN. POPULATION
JUST BECAUSE OF ALL. WHAT THEY
CALL THE CHINA VIRUS A ONE
VIRUS. I'M WE CANNOT DEPARTING
CONTINUE CONTINUING. FOR
BLAMING EACH OTHER FOR
DIFFERENT COURSES. WE NEED TO
STAND UP TOGETHER AND TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND THE WE
ARE THE ONES SO INTO EACH
DISTRICT. WE CAN TAKE A MATCH
ON AND OFF DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT AND THE LEAD THE PEOPLE.
THAT WE WOULD NOT TOLERATE SUCH
A HATE CRIME AGAINST ALL
MONITORED. EACH OTHER. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE ON HR
TWENTY THREE AND TO SPEAK UP
FOR THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR CHOI MISTER GIBSON IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WISH
TO THANK THE MEMBER FROM
CAMPBELL. FOR BRINGING FORTH
THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE US TODAY.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
THREE TO DENOUNCE THE HATE
CRIMES THE RHETORIC. AND THE
ACTIONS AGAINST MY ASIAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. I RISE
STRONGLY TO CONDEMN THE RECENT
STRING OF ATTACKS ON MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF API
COMMUNITY. MEMBERS YOU SEE WE
CELEBRATE THE LUNAR NEW YEAR'S
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT
HOLIDAY FOR THE API COMMUNITY.
IT IS A TIME FOR FAMILIES TO
COME TOGETHER TO CELEBRATE A
NEW BEGINNING. IT IS TIME TO
CELEBRATE TRADITION AND FOCUS
ON THE FUTURE. IT HURTS THAT
THIS NEW YEAR HAS BROUGHT SO
MUCH HURT AND PAIN AND VIOLENCE.
TO NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THIS WHOLE NATION IT
HURTS TO KNOW THAT MY áP ARE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE BEING
ATTACKED. AND MEMBERS IT HURTS
TO KNOW THAT THE HATRED IS HERE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE
JUST LIKE IT HAS BEEN FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. THIS IS THE
PAST PRESIDENT USE WORDS TO
TARGET THE API COMMUNITY. JEFF
SLIDE HE'S ATTACKED OTHER
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. HE CALLED
IT THE CHINA FLEW. AND OTHER.
WORDS BLAMING THEM FOR THIS
PANDEMIC. AND NOW PEOPLE ARE
BEING HURT. HER LAST. AND YES
EVEN MURDER ON OUR STREETS. BUT
WHERE THERE IS COMMUNITY. THERE
IS STRENGTH WHERE THERE IS
COMMUNITY THERE IS RESILIENCE
AND IT UNDENIABLE FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE. WE KNOW IT FEBRUARY IS
BLACK HISTORY MONTH. OUR STORY
IN THIS COUNTRY IS ABOUT
OVERCOMING. MY COMMUNITY KNOWS
ABOUT HATRED BECAUSE THIS
CHRONICLE IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS
WE KNOW ABOUT HATE CRIMES
BECAUSE THIS STARTED WITH US.
WE FEAR WE RECOGNIZE IT AND WE
CALL IT OUT. IT IS A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. I
AM HERE TO STAND SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER. WITH MY APR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AGAINST HATE. LET
ME LET US COME TOGETHER. AS ONE
FAMILY. THE CASE FOR INCLUSION
NOT EXCLUSION FOR PEACE AND NOT
WAR FOR ACCEPTANCE AND NOT
BIGOTRY HELLO ANON HATE. LET US
TOGETHER. THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL LET
ME CLOSE BY SAYING THIS. BY
JAMES BALDWIN HE SAID WE CAN
JUST QUICKER DISAGREE AND STILL
LOVE EACH OTHER UNLESS. THINK
ME AND DID NOT A MYANMAR
HUMANITY AND THE RIGHT TO EXIST
I STRONGLY OUT BUT I BOTH WHAT
H. R. TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON. MR VOEPEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. I SUPPORT HR TWENTY
THREE. AND. I HAVE A REQUEST
FOR A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR MY
VERY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN JOSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. VERY WELL SO
SUPPORT THIS BILL GREAT BILL
THANK YOU SIR. BUT I'M ALWAYS
VERY SENSITIVE IT'S LIKE A
LITTLE NERVOUS TO ME OKAY A
LITTLE NERVOUS TWITCHING ABOUT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT. SO MY
QUESTION TO MY BROTHER
COLLEAGUES. IS WHAT EXACTLY IS
THE DEFINITION OF HATEFUL
RHETORIC UNDER THIS BILL
BECAUSE THAT COULD BE TWISTED
AND TURNED BY ANYBODY. SIR
SHOW YOU MAY CHOOSE ANSWERED
OUR NICHOLS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS BIGGER I AM DETAIL
LIKE TO AFTER THE CLOSE. THANK
YOU MICHELLE. MISTER CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY THREE AS
THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FORTY
NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH IS
ALSO THE FIRST MEETING MAJORITY
ASIAN AMERICAN ELECTORAL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA. LAST
FRIDAY AS MANY OF US CELEBRATED
THE LUNAR LUNAR NEW YEAR. THE
API CAUCUS HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE TO DENOUNCE THE
GROWING INCIDENCE OF HATE
CRIMES THAT MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. HAVE EXPERIENCED
ACROSS THE STATE DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. UNFORTUNATELY ON THAT
VERY DAY THE MEDIA REPORTED
THAT AN INSULTING MESSAGE WAS
SCRAWLED IN HUMAN FECES ON THE
FRONT DOOR OF AN ASIAN ALL PRE
SCHOOL IN THE CITY OF ALHAMBRA.
IN MY DISTRICT. WHICH WAS THE
LATEST HATE FILLED ATTACK
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS. TO SAY
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS TURNED
OUR LIVES UPSIDE DOWN IT'S
TRULY AN UNDERSTATEMENT. YET
FOR MANY API'S IT HAS ALSO
BECOME VERY PERSONAL. SIMILAR
TO A TIME BOMB WAITING TO
EXPLODE TRIGGERED BY FEELINGS
OF ANGER AND FEAR LASHED OUT
AGAINST US AND MANIFESTED
THROUGH VERBAL AND PHYSICAL
ATTACKS. SIMILAR INCIDENTS
BEGAN SURFACING SINCE APRIL OF
LAST YEAR. WHEN WE LEARNED
ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ADMITTED TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AFTER AN ATTACK BY BULLIES WHO
ACCUSED HIM OF HAVING THE VIRUS.
THE FOURTH GRADE TEACHER WHO
HEARD A STUDENT SAY KILL THE
CHINESE. A FAMILY WHOSE VEHICLE
WAS VANDALIZED WITH HATEFUL
MESSAGE REFERENCING CORONAVIRUS.
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE API SO ALSO
VICTIMS OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION YES
LASHING OUT ONCE RESTORATION OF
THAT WOULD VIOLENCE AGAINST API
COMMUNITY IS WRONG. VIOLENCE
WILL NOT BRING THIS PANDEMIC TO
AN END BUT IT WILL CONSOLE
DIVISIONS AMONG US COMMUNITIES
AND UNDERMINED THE TRUST THAT
IS NECESSARY TO DEFEAT THIS
VIRUS. IN FACT MANY API GROUPS
TOOK THE INITIATIVE TO RAISE
MONEY IN A QUIET PP PUTS PEOPLE
IN NEED. FOR EXAMPLE IN A SAN
DIEGO VALLEY AREA WHICH IS WHY
REPRESENT MORE THAN A MILLION A
PP PIECES WERE DONATED TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN WEEKS OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE ARE FIGHTING THE
SAME BATTLE. IF WE ARE TO
PREVAIL DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES WE MUST
ADDRESS ISSUES OF
DISCRIMINATION. BY DISPELLING
NEGATIVE IMAGES AND ATTITUDES
AND HIGHLIGHTING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR STATE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. LET US
PUSH BACK ON THOSE WHO THROUGH
ACTS OF DISCRIMINATION. SEEK TO
DIVIDE US. WE MUST STAND UNITED
AND THIS OF ALL VIOLENCE WHEN
WE SEE IT. ESPECIALLY WHEN
MOTIVATED BY HATE. HEY CRIMES
HAVE NO PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY
PLEASE FILL AYE ON HR TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHELLE MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY THREE MY
COLLECTION CABLE I HEAR YOUR
PASSION I HEAR ANGER AND I
SUPPORT YOU. UNCOMMITTED BASED
ON HATE AND IGNORANCE OR GERM
INTOLERANCE DIRECTOR THE GROUP
INDIVIDUAL HAVING COMMON
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS RACE
RACE. ETHNICITY RELIGION
NATIONALITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
GENDER EVEN PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
OR PHYSICAL DISABILITIES. HEY
MOTIVATED CRIMES CAN INCLUDE
ACTS SUCH AS VERBAL THREATS.
PROPERTY DAMAGE ASSAULT. AND
EVEN MURDER. CALIFORNIA
PENALIZE THOSE CONVICTED OF
HATE CRIMES WITH MISDEMEANORS
OR FELONY CONVICTIONS. IN THE
MOST SEVERE CASES THE PERSON TO
BE SENT TO STATE PRISON. STATE
PRISON CONDITIONS MEAN THE
PERPETRATOR ACTED VIOLENTLY THE
VICTIM OF VICTIM SUFFERED GREAT
INJURY BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
PSYCHOLOGICALLY. SADLY THESE
TYPES OF CONVICTIONS ARE
CONSIDERED NON. UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW. AND ALLOW FOR
THE PERPETRATOR TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EARLY PRO
OPPORTUNITIES. ONLY. SERVING A
FRACTION OF THEIR SINS. MEMBERS
WE HATE CRIMES ARE GOING. NOT
GOING DOWN. THIS IS HR SERVICE
RESOLUTION TO RUN A PRESS THE
GREEN BUTTON THAT'S PRETTY EASY
TO PRESS. BUT WHAT'S THANK MORE
PRESSING LATER THIS YEAR YOU'LL
BE OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. YOU'LL SEE
BILLS THAT WOULD ADDRESS HATE
CRIMES. HAVE GONE UP. HONG KONG
FLU THE ASIAN FLU I MEAN YOU
HEAR THAT EVERYDAY. TALK ABOUT
API WITH THE TRANSGENDER OF
DRAMATICALLY MUSLIM OF
DRAMATICALLY. AND OTHERS IN OUR
COUNTRY SO HOW DO WE PROTECT.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE ONE SET UP
INCIDENT SUPPORT SUPPORT
SUPPORT THAT'S GREAT IT'S A
RESOLUTION BUT LATER ON THIS
YEAR. WHO CAN STAND UP FOR THE
VICTIMS IN THIS. BECAUSE
SOMEONE CONVICTED OF A HATE
CRIME A VIOLENT HATE CRIME. YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU SHOULD GO TO
PRISON. IF YOU'RE BURNED OUT A
SYNAGOGUE KELOWNA API COMMUNITY
MEMBER. OR SOME OTHER
TRANSGENDER. FOR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. YOU DESERVE SEVERE
PUNISHMENT THE RIVER IS THE
WHAT HAPPENED THERE THIS YEAR.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE A LOT
OF FAITH IN YOU IF WE DO THE
RIGHT THING AND WHO WE STAND
FOR. THAT'S WE WILL COME DOWN
TO SELL I URGE YOU SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION IS A GREAT
RESOLUTION AND MY BROTHER FROM
CAMPBELL. THANK YOU I LOVE YOU.
AMOS COOPER. MR LEE. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
RISING AND EXPRESSING A STRONG
SOLITUDE WITH US ALL THE
ALREADY WITH US AND YOUR
SUPPORT I REPRESENTS A DISTRICT
THAT IS A PLURALITY ASIAN
AMERICANS NOT QUITE LIKE THE
FORTY NINTH DISTRICT WHICH IS A
MAJORITY OF ASIAN AMERICANS
THAT WE DO HAVE A COMPETITION
OF WHO HAS THE BETTER FOOD
ASIAN FOOD OUR DISTRICT- BUT I
WILL SAY THAT I'VE HEARD A LOT
OF COMMENTS WHERE PEOPLE DO
FEEL UNHEARD THEY FEEL
NEGLECTED. A LOT ASIAN
AMERICANS YOUNG AND OLD FEEL
SCARED RIGHT NOW AND THEY FEEL
PERHAPS EVEN WORSE IGNORED THEY
FEEL INVISIBLE AND THIS IS A
CENTRAL STRUGGLE TODAY'S
AMERICAN IDENTIFYING A VISIBLE
UNTIL RECENTLY UNTIL RECENTLY
THAT THE NEW START TALKING
ABOUT IT AND WE START TALKING
MORE ABOUT IT PEOPLE START
FEELING LIKE THEIR CONCERNS ARE
BEING HEARD AND THAT IS THE
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP. IN
ADDRESSING THESE HATE CRIMES IN
ADDRESSING THE PAIN THAT ARE
COMMITTEES ARE SUFFERING.
LEWNARD NEW YEAR WHICH
CELEBRATED THIS PAST WEEKEND.
IS NORMALLY A TIME OF
CELEBRATION FOR FAMILIES. BUT
THIS YEAR WE'RE FACING FEAR AND
UNREST. MANY OF US COULDN'T
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE OX.
LIKE MYSELF WITH MY
GRANDPARENTS BECAUSE OF THE BAD
DEMOCRATS. A BUDGET MAKE THAT
WE OFTEN. ARE UNFAIRLY
SCAPEGOATED FOR AND IS IT. A
SURPRISE AT ALL IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WE HAVE RISE IN ASIAN HATE
CRIMES WHEN YOU ADD A SITTING
PRESIDENT. VALIDATE CLAIMS SUCH
AS THE WUHAN VIRUS THE CHINESE
VIRUS WHATEVER RACIAL EPITHET
YOU COME UP WITH. AND YOU HAVE
HEARD OF PARROTED ACROSS. THE
COUNTRY. THAT'S THE COUNTRY WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW AND THIS IS THE
REASON APART A LARGE PART OF
WHY WE HAVE THESE THINGS. JUST
LAST WEEK IN SAN JOSE IN THE
CITY THAT I REPRESENTS A SIXTY
FOR ALL GRANT SIXTY FOUR YEAR
OLD GRANDMOTHER WAS ROBBED IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT. AHEAD OF LUNAR
NEW YEAR. THIS IS HAPPENING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. TIMES
ARE OF COURSE TOUGH AND PEOPLE
ARE FRUSTRATED BUT OUR ASIAN
ELDERS WHO ARE THE MOST REVERED
MEMBERS ARE COMMUNITIES ARE
INNOCENT OF A LARGER FORCES AT
PLAY POWER CAUSING THESE
THINGS. I AM COMMITTED WITH MY
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES API
CAUCUSES ALL THIS CHAMBER TO BE
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
XENOPHOBIA OF RACISM AND CRIME.
AND THAT BEGINS. A TOUGH NEW
ONCE CONVERSATION ABOUT CRIME
ABOUT THE ROLE RACE AND SOCIETY
AND I DO BELIEVE THE ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS READY TO
HAVE A- DISCUSSION. JUST OVER
THE WEEKEND I WAS HEARTENED TO
SEE THE ORGANIZING GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZING DONE IN OAKLAND
CHINATOWN AS WELL AS MANY OTHER
CHINATOWNS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S DISPLAYED IN FULL
DISPLAY V. INTER GENERATIONAL
AND INTERRACIAL SOLAR THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN WITH BETWEEN ALL
RACES. BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
THERE WILL BE THOSE WHO. SEEK
TO EXPLOIT SOME FACTS OF THESE
INSTANCES TO PUT A WEDGE
BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITIES. I AM
NOT I CANNOT RECOUNT YOU HOW
MANY TIMES I'VE SEEN EVEN OTHER
ASIAN AMERICANS TO SAY VERY
VERY NASTY THINGS. AND JUMP TO
CONCLUSIONS BUT THAT'S ALRIGHT
IT'S GOT TO COME OUT OF PLACE
OF FEAR. AND SOMETIMES FEAR CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR WITH. SO
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO KEEP THE
OLIDARITY KEEP WORKING
TOGETHER AND KEEP WORKING
COMMITTEE DRIVEN APPROACHES
TOGETHER BECAUSE WE ARE
STRONGER WHEN WE ARE SHOULDER
WE'RE SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
OUR BLACK SIBLINGS WITH OUR
BROWN'S DOUBLING. AND OUR
NATIVE SAID LET'S JUST SAYS
THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY. HAS PUT
MANY MANY CHALLENGES IN FRONT
OF ALL OUR COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
STRONGER WHEN WE ARE FIGHTING
TOGETHER AGAINST STRUCTURAL
ISSUES THAT ARE CAUSING THESE
THINGS. AND SOMETIMES THESE
ANSWERS WILL BE TOUGH THEY'LL
BE NUANCE AND THEY'LL BE HARD
TO HEAR BUT THOSE ARE THE
CHALLENGES WE MUST OVERCOME.
ORGANISING I'VE SEEN AMONG THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY THAT
WE ARE READY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT FULLY. WITH YOU ALL. SO
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE ATTENTION.
AND THE PASSION WE HAVE IN THIS
CHAMBER AND I FEEL FOR ONE
THAT'S- THE HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS NOT
IGNORED THIS CHAMBER. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING. THE NEW YEAR
IS A CHANCE TO START AGAIN AND
A SHARE IN THE HOPE OF GOOD
THINGS TO COME. TWENTY TWENTY
THEYEAR OF THE OX. WHICH IS
SAID TO BRING STABILITY AND-CALMNESS. AND I'M HOPEFUL WE
WILL EMERGE. FROM THE STRONGER
AS A COMMUNITY WITH OUR ALLIES
STRONGER AND CALMER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LATE MR
GABRIEL. WE ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HR TWENTY THREE. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY WE STAND
STRONGLY IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
API CAUCUS AND WITH THE API
COMMUNITY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. AS JEWS WE ARE
ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE POWER OF HATE
CRIMES OF THE POWER OF HATE AND
BIGOTRY. WE KNOW WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO BE TARGETED WE KNOW
WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO HAVE
METAL DETECTORS AND ARMED
GUARDS OUTSIDE OF OUR COMMUNITY
CENTERS AND OUR HOUSES OF
WORSHIP. IT'S FOR THIS REASON
THAT WE ARE SO DISHEARTENED AND
OUTRAGED. BY THIS SENSELESS
VIOLENCE AND THE REALLY UGLY
BIGOTRY THAT WE ARE WITNESSING
AGAINST THE API COMMUNITY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TODAY.
I WAS DISCUSSING WITH M
COLLEAGUE FROM CAMPBELL LAST
WEEK SOME OF THE SIMILARITIES
ABOUT THE HATE AND
DISCRIMINATION THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES FACE ABOUT THE FACT
THAT. THEY COME FROM RECYCLED
STEREO TYPES FOR BIGOTRY THAT
HAS REARED ITS HEAD IN THE
PAST. THAT PLAYS ON THE FEAR OF
THE OTHER. ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
THAT'S OFTEN PRECEDED BY
HATEFUL RHETORIC BY PEOPLE WHO
MAY BE SPEAKING IN CODE. BUT
THAT CODE IS UNDERSTOOD AND
INSIGHTS ACTION. BY THE FACT
THAT NO MATTER WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES CONTRIBUTE NO
MATTER HOW HARD WE TRY. THIS
UNDERLYING SENSE THAT MAYBE
WE'RE NOT SURE RECALLS MAYBE
WE'RE NOT REALLY REALLY WELCOME
HERE BY EVERYBODY. AND WE KNOW
AS AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY SAID THAT
HATE CRIMES DON'T JUST IMPACT
INDIVIDUAL VICTIMS. THAT THEY
THEY HAVE A BROADER IMPACT ON
THE TARGETED COMMUNITY ON OTHER
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FOLKS
THAT FEEL HATE AND ULTIMATELY
ON THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE.
THAT IS OUR CLOCKS AND THEY ARE
MEANT TO DIVIDE US AND THAT IS
WHY ALLY SHIP AND PARTNERSHIP
ARE SO ESSENTIAL HERE. I WOULD
SAY ONE OF FOR ME IN MY SHORT
TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE ONE OF
THE MOST MEANINGFUL MOMENTS FOR
ME. WAS THE WAY IN WHICH THE A.
P. I. CAUCUS. AND ALL OF THE
OTHER CAUCUSES IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP STOOD
WITH THE JEWISH CAUCUS AFTER
THE ATTACK THE DEADLY ATTACK.
AGAINST THE SYNAGOGUE IN POWER.
AND HOW MUCH THAT MEANT TO ME
PERSONALLY AND HOW MUCH THAT
MEANT TO OUR JEWISH CAUCUS AND
HOW MUCH THAT MEANT TO THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TO SEE ALL OF.
THE OTHER COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE. STAND BY OUR SIDE. AND
pIMPORTANT THE API COMMUNITY
FEEL THE SAME SENSE OF SUPPORT.
I FEEL THE SAME SENSE OF ALLY
SHIP. I HOPE THAT OUR API
COLLEAGUES IN THE IF I
COMMUTING THE STATE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. HAVE YOUR BACK. WE
STAND STRONGLY WITH YOU. THAT
WE DEEPLY VALUE YOU. THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT OUR
INCREDIBLE API COMMUNITY. AND
THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO TAKING
ACTION TO PROTECT YOUR- AND WE
KNOW TO THAT END WE KNOW THAT
THAT FROM OUR STATE AUDITOR
THAT HATE CRIMES ARE
DRAMATICALLY UNDER REPORTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO
WE KNOW THAT THIS SPIKE IN HATE
THAT WE ARE SEEING AGAINST THE
APEC COMMUNITY. THAT'S PROBABLY
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG AS
MUCH AS THOSE NUMBERS ARE
JUMPED UP IN AN ALARMING RATE
THAT IS THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
AND WHAT THIS COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCING WHAT COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING. AND IT IS FOR
THAT REASON THAT THE JEWISH
CAUCUS HAS DECIDED THAT THIS
SESSION WE WILL MAKE
CONFRONTING HATE CRIMES ONE OF
OUR LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE API CAUCUS AND ALL OF THE
CAUCUSES IN THIS BUILDING TO
ADVANCE MEANINGFUL LEGISLATION
THAT WILL ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
AND I THINK THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS A STRONG AND
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN THAT
EFFORT SO I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING FORTH
THIS RESOLUTION FOR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF IT. I WANT TO
REAFFIRM THE ALLY SHIP OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY AND THE JEWISH
CAUCUS AND I STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE. ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK GABRIEL MISTER. BONTA
YOUR- IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
THREE AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THE AUTHOR I DEEPLY. THIS BODY
LOUDLY AND WITH ONE VOICE
CONDEMNING AND DENOUNCING THESE
UNACCEPTABLE ACTS OF HATE AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST API. COMMUNITY
AS OTHERS SPEAKERS HAVE ALREADY
DETAILED API COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
HAVE TO OFTEN BEEN VICTIMS OF
THE IN A PHOBIA. OF OTHERING OF
SCAPEGOATING AND PHYSICAL
ATTACKS. INCLUDING TRAGICALLY
MURDER IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN
OAKLAND'S CHINATOWN WE'VE SEEN
THE HORRIFIC AND THE VICIOUS
AND GRAPHIC ATTACKS ON OUR-
BELOVED ELDERS. THESE ATTACKS
WE ALL KNOW ARE UNACCEPTABLE
AND WE SIMPLY CANNOT AND WILL
NOT TOLERATE THEM AS HAS BEEN
STATED AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RESTATE ALL COMMUNITIES ALL
COMMUNITIES DESERVE TO BE SEEN.
TO BE PROTECTED TO BE VALUED
AND APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS ON
THOSE POINTS BY SO MANY
SPEAKERS TODAY. FOR ME IN TIMES
LIKE THESE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR IS INESCAPABLE NETWORK
OF MUTUALITY ARE FUNDAMENTAL
INTERCONNECTEDNESS WHICH IS-
AT- ON FULL DISPLAY HERE ON THE
FLOOR WITH THE COMMENTS AND THE
COMMITMENTS TO ALLY SHIP. AND
THAT SPIRIT I AM API CAUCUS ARE
JUST THE GRATEFUL- FOR THE MANY
MEANINGFUL ACCESS AND
COMMITMENTS OF SOLIDARITY AN
ALLY SHIP FROM OTHER
COMMUNITIES KNOW ALL TOO WELL.
FROM LONG HISTORIES AND
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE TARGETED FOR ABUSE.
BASED ON THEIR IDENTITY. YEAH
INCLUDES THE OUR IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY CAME OUT IN FORCE
OVER THE WEEKEND IN OAKLAND IN
MY DISTRICT. TO RALLY AGAINST
ANTI API HATE. AND IT INCLUDES
THE SUPPORT OF THE MANY ALLIES.
ON THIS FLOOR TODAY THANK YOU.
TO GET ELECTED DO YOU TO
COLLABORATE TO COALESCE. AND TO
CO CREATE SOLUTIONS THAT
PREVENT THAT RESTORE. THAT
HE'LL AND THAT PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SAFETY. WITH
API COMMUNITY AND ALL
COMMUNITIES SUFFERING FROM
ATTACKS AND FROM HATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON HR TWENTY THREE. THANK MR
BONTA KALRA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ALL I
WANNA ALSO EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION TO A COLLEAGUE
FROM CAMPBELL AUTO AND ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
SPOKEN- IN SOLIDARITY IN
PARTICULAR IN SOLIDARITY
ALIGNED WITH BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. I THINK THAT IT CAN'T BE
UNDERSTATED THAT WE CANNOT-
REVERSAL CAN'T UNDERSTATE THE
AMOUNT OF PAIN THAT'S BEING
FELT THAT IS. AS HAPPY
ESPECIALLY DOOR ELDER AND I
THINK EVERY. AND ANYONE THAT
THE PACK COMMUNITY NO. HOW
PROTECT OUR ELDERS AND CARING
FOR THEM AND- THE RESPECT WE
HAVE FOR ELDERS THAT IT'S
ESPECIALLY HEARTBREAKING TO
SEE. OUR ELDERS- BEING HURT AND
THEN TO HAVE US FEELING
HELPLESS IN TRYING. TO HEAL
THEM AND PROTECT THEM- YOU KNOW
I ALSO. I'VE ALWAYS I WOULD
CAUTION US TO NOT TEMPTED TO
USE THIS IS OPPORTUNITY DIVIDE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHY
I'M A SPECIALLY GRATEFUL. AS WE
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
FOR- OR BLOCK CALLING STEP UP
AND CAN YOU- WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
POINT THAT. OR OR LOCALLY AND
SO A ASIAN AMERICAN COMMITTEE
BALL JOINED SIXTY OTHER API AND
OUR ORGANS TO CAUTION AS WELL.
DURING THE RECALL PERSONAL.
THAT ADDRESS THE CAUSE OF SO
VIOLENCE INVEST IN EDGE REACHED.
THANK BASED. THANK CONDUCTING
COST CAN AND PROMOTE EMPATHY.
AND ASSURED RESPONSE FOR AND TO
VIOLENCE AND COMMUNAL HEARING.
PRIVATIZING COMMITTEE BASE
RESPONSE. TO PROTECT-COMMUNITIES DOES NOT INVOLVE ON
LONG PREVENTION. A PERPETUAL BY
LIVE AND TRAUMA BLACK AND BROWN
CAN. OUR COMMUNITIES OF
ORGANIZED IN ADVANCE COMMITTEE
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE SAFETY
PROJECT. YOU MUST HONOR THIS
WISDOM AND EXPERIENCE AND USE
IT TO GUIDE SOLUTIONS NOW. AND
AS WE SEE THE VISCERAL AND
PAINFUL. INCIDENTS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AGAINST SO MANY AND A
PACKET ESPECIALLY OUR ELDERS
THAT HAS RECOGNIZED THAT HE
MUST RISE RECOGNIZE THAT PAIN.
BUT IS ALSO RECOGNIZED THE NOT
SO VISCERAL PAIN AND HURT IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN AN EFFORT TO
UNIFY INCLUDING THE
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH AND
DISPROPORTIONATE PEOVER DEATH
RATES AMONG THE LATINO AFTER
AMERICAN AND FILIPINO
COMMUNITIES. BUT AS RECOGNIZE
THE POVERTY THAT IS BEING FELT
DEEPLY IN OUR COMMUNITY AT THE
SAME TIME AS THE WEALTHY ARE
GETTING WEALTHIER THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE CAN UNITE- WE
CAN NIGHT- UNITE AROUND IN
COMMON A LOVE THAT I BELIEVE
WILL HELP TO FUEL AGAINST THIS
RASH OF CRIMES AGAINST OR API
ELDERS. AND ALL AND WITH AN.
ANECDOTE ABOUT A YOUNG ADJUSTED
TO THE SPEED OF FACT THAT THIS
CAN BE HAPPEN ANYONE AND IT
IT'S TO ALL US WITH A NOTED-
YOUNG IN REGISTER WHO ARE IS
YOUNG Y. AND BABY AT HOME. WHO-
WAS. STOP BY A VEHICLE OF THE
STOPPED IN FRONT OF THEM. WAS
PUNCHES WAS DRIVEN INTO A AS
YOU WAS BEING PROFANITIES. THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED.
A FEW DAYS AGO A FEW AGO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT OVER ONE YEARS
AGO TO MY FOR. WHEN HE A THE
NEW IMMIGRANT BEFORE HAS WHEN
YOU'RE A NEW AND IN CANADA.
THERE'S A LOT OF ANTI-
IMMIGRANT TOWARDS PEOPLE LIKE
HIM. WHEN I FAMILY FIRST CAME
TO APARTMENT- AND SO. THESE
ISSUES ARE PER. THE REAL AND I
THINK WE CAN GET THROUGH THEM
TOGETHER BUT IF WE UNDER. ALL
THE PAIN THAT'S BEING FELT I
UNDERSTAND ALSO THAT WERE MUCH
STRONGER UNITED IN SOLIDARITY
AND LOVE WITH ONE ANOTHER. I DO
HAVE TO HELP HEAL US THROUGH.-THIS TIME SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A YEAR AHEAD AS
WE CELEBRATE LUNAR NEW YEAR THE
BE ALL. GOOD CAN HEAL FROM
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC BEYOND THE
STATE CRIMES ARE IN AND LOVING
COMMUNITY SPIRIT THANK YOU.
DAVIS MISS BARROWS HAN YOU ARE
UNDER THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER. I RISE IN SOLIDARITY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
CAMPBELL AS WELL HE OPENED HIS
REMARKS BY SAYING THAT WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER HISTORY. OR WE WERE
P. DAY. TWO YEARS AGO I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF STANDING ON THE
FLOOR ON HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY AND TELL YOU ALL ABOUT MY
GRANDMOTHER. AND HOW SHE HAD TO
FLEE HER ONLY HOME. BECAUSE SHE
WAS GONNA BE KILLED FOR BEING
JEWISH. I WANT US TO REMEMBER.
THAT THE WHOLE DIDN'T START
WITH DEATH CAMPS. AND EVENTS
WHERE BODIES WERE BURNED. IT
STARTED WITH HATEFUL RHETORIC
WITH PROPAGANDA WITH SLURS WITH
CRIMES ON THE STREET THAT
KILLED JEWS. AND OTHER ETHNIC
MINORITIES. AND THEN WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT IS HAPPENING
TODAY. AND WE NEED TO SPEAK
ABOUT IT AND SPEAK LOUDLY IN IN
SOLIDARITY AND IN ONE VOICE. TO
CONDEMN ACTS. TO CONDEMN THE
ACTUALLY CAN FOR OUR API
COMMUNITY WE HEARD FOR CALLING
FROM SANTA MONICA. WHO CHAIRS
THE SELECT ME ON HATE CRIMES
AND HATE CRIMES ARE ON THE RISE
ACROSS THIS STATE AND ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY. AND WE AS LEADERS
CAN NOT SIT SILENTLY BY. WE
HAVE TO SPEAK UP BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
THIS TIME. THEN WHEN MY FAMILY
HAD TO FLEE FOR THEIR LIFE AND
SO. MANY LOST THEIR LIVES TO
HATRED. AND SO I- JUST ALL
TODAY TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE API. CAUCUS TO TAKE TO
WOULD HAVE IN OUR CITY. THE P.
ARE DYING. BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN. TO AS WE
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
REMEMBER HISTORY AS A NATION
AND WE HAVE SO MUCH HEALING TO
DO AND IT IS ONLY BEGUN IF EVEN
THAT. AND THEN LOOK TOWARDS THE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE WILL HAVE
OVER THE COMING MONTHS TO DO
THE WORK THAT CALIFORNIANS NEED
US TO DO. YOU HEARD FROM
SEVERAL OF OUR COLLEAGUES THAT
BILLS THAT WILL COME FORWARD.
BILLS ON EDUCATION TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN TEACH OUR
YOUTH BETTER SO THEY WILL BE
BETTER. BILLS THAT WILL COUNTY
AND ENSURE THESE CRIMES ARE
TRACKED. AND THEN WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM. THE
PEOPLE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
WHEN THEY DO THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW ARE WRONG. AND I- JUST
COME TOGETHER. REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS AT THE CAUCUSES TO
SUPPORT THESE BILLS. BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHO IS GOING TO NEED
THEM NEXT BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY AGAINST
HATE CRIMES. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT AND I URGE IN AB.
THERE WAS BURKE A HAND MISS
CLARK SILVA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR MY DESK. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I STAND ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN ECHO THE
CHORUS THAT WINDOW WE SAY
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH. AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE STATED AND MANY
HAVE REPEATED WHEN DO WE SAY
WHETHER IT'S AN ELDER. FROM AN
API COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S A
LATINO. WHETHER IT'S SOMEBODY
FROM OUR BLACK COMMUNITY THIS
IS ENOUGH. AS A TEACHER MANY
MANY TIMES WE CELEBRATE BLACK
HISTORY MONTH VALENTINE'S DAY
AND API LUNAR NEW YEAR ALL FOR
CELEBRATION BUT WE DON'T TALK.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THE DEEP
PAIN AND TRAUMA. THAT WE KNOW
INDIVIDUALS HAVE HAD TO DEAL
WITH. MEMBERS I CAN HEAR THE
PAIN ON THIS FLOOR FROM MEMBER
SPEAKING BECAUSE MANY OF US
INDIVIDUALLY HAVE HAD PAIN
INFLICTED ON US OR OUR FAMILIES
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF OUR
SKIN. AND AS WE LOOK TO STOP
SOME OF THIS IT SIMPLY IS THE
WORD STOP WHEN DO WE SAY
WHETHER THE ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES HOEKS SAYS
THOSE PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY THE RATE FOR THEIR
MURDERERS AND SAY THAT THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH. WHEN DO WE SAY THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TAKEN TO SEE
JOHN THE CAPITAL. THAT THAT'S
ENOUGH IT'S UP TO US TO SAY
SOMETHING WE SEE SOMETHING.
IT'S UP TO US TO INTERVENE AND
NOT STAND BY IDLY AND TELL WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR OWN COMMUNITY.
AND TOO OFTEN WE SEE THAT IS A
BULLY AND PEOPLE STAND BY AND
WATCH. AND IT'S UP TO US WHEN
WE HEAR SOMETHING EVEN WITHIN
OUR CIRCLES OR SOCIAL MEDIA. TO
STAND UP AND SAY I'M GONNA
REPORT YOU. WHAT CAN WE DO HERE.
WE CAN SUPPORT ETHNIC STUDIES
WHICH ETHNIC STUDIES IS ABOUT
TEACHING HISTORY THAT'S WHAT
IT'S ABOUT IT'S NOT A SCARY
THING MANY OF OUR FAMILIES HAVE
COME HERE WHETHER IT'S FROM API
COMMUNITIES FROM LATINO
COMMUNITIES THEY'VE CROSSED
BORDERS THEY RISK THEIR LIFE
FOR A SAFER PLACE TO LIVE. AND
WE ARE NOT SAFE FOR NOW SO IT'S
TIME FOR US TO COME TOGETHER.
FROM ALL ETHNIC CAUCUSES AND
FROM ALL RACES AND RELIGIONS TO
SAY WE'RE MERICANS AND WE'RE
GOING TO HELP EACH OTHER AS
NEIGHBORS AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AS PARENTS AS EDUCATORS AS WE
CANNOT TOLERATE THIS HATE AND
BIGOTRY I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
HR TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MR
CORK SILVA MISTER MURPHY G. IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I WOULD
LIKE TO. THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM ALL DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES FROM ALL PARTS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
HAS SPOKEN. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. YEAH MY COMMUNITY.
I A POINT WAS MADE VIA API
CAUCUS HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE-
LAST TO FRIDAY AND- WELL WE-
HIGHLIGHTED HOW. THESE ANTI
ASIAN ATTACKS ARE HAPPENING IN
EVERY PART OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN EVERY PART OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. EVER
SINCE THIS PANDEMIC STARTED
THERE IS THERE ARE- A
COLLABORATION OF- WONDERFUL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE FORMED THIS- THIS OF
REPORTING SITE STOP áP I HATE.
.ORG AND THEY EVER SINCE THE
PANDEMIC OF STARTED THEY HAVE
COMPILED OVER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED INCIDENTS OF HATE
CRIMES AGAINST ASIANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW MY OWN
COMMUNITY I REPRESENT- MOSTLY
SUBURBAN COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE'VE HAD OUR
SHARE OF HIGH PROFILE ANTI
ASIAN INCIDENTS WE HAD YOU KNOW
WELL THIS THIS ONE WOMAN WAS
CAPTURED ON VIDEOTAPE AND- IT
WENT VIRAL FOR A WHILE SHE
FORTUNATELY WAS CONVICTED IN
CRIMINAL COURT-FOR COMMITTING
A HATE CRIME- COMMITTING
BATTERY AGAINST- AN ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN IN THIS CASE A
FILIPINO AMERICAN WOMAN. SHE
ALSO OF VERBALLY ASSAULTED A
JAPANESE AMERICAN FAMILY YOU
KNOW WHICH HIGHLIGHTS THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHILE. WHILE
PEOPLE MAY BE TAKING THEIR
FRUSTRATIONS OUT BECAUSE OF
THIS YOU KNOW- THIS WAY WITH
WHAT THEY HEAR IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A CHINESE VIRUS OF WUHAN
VIRUS I MEAN YOU KNOW ALL THIS
HATEFUL RHETORIC COMING. FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON DOWN. THAT
IN THE EYES OF THE HATERS WE
ALL LOOK THE SAME YOU KNOW
WHETHER YOU'RE A FILIPINO
AMERICAN WHETHER YOU'RE
JAPANESE AMERICAN. MEAN PART OF
THE ATTACK ON ON ON THE OF THE
FILIPINO AMERICAN WOMAN AND THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN FAMILY AND
WILSON PARK IN THE CITY OF
TORRANCE NORMALLY GOES VERY LAW
ABIDING VERY PEACEFUL COMMUNITY.
ONE OF THE MOST HATEFUL WORDS
THAT EVERY ASIAN AMERICAN
RECOGNIZED HER SAYING IS GO
BACK TO WHERE YOU CAME FROM.
EVERY AYE I WOULD SUSPECT THAT
EVERY ASIAN AMERICAN ON THIS
FLOOR HAS HEARD THOSE WORDS GO
BACK TO WHERE YOU CAME FROM
EVEN FOR A THIRD GENERATION
JAPANESE AMERICAN LIKE MYSELF.
YOU KNOW OR OR WHETHER YOU'RE A
FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT I
MEAN THAT. YEAH THOSE WORDS GO
BACK TO WHERE YOU CAME FROM
THAT THAT THAT REALLY. CAPTURES
YOU KNOW V. PERPETUAL OUTSIDER
STATUS OF SO MANY ASIAN
AMERICANS- LET LIVING AND IN
CALIFORNIA LIVING IN THE
COUNTRY AND SO YOU KNOW. I
REALLY APPRECIATE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT THEY
pWERE GETTING- AND THIS TIME A
CRISIS- AS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO INDICATED EARLIER
WERE WORKING ON A BILL TO
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE HATE
CRIME HOTLINE. SO THAT YOU KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON THESE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT
WE SHOULD MAKE IT EASIER MAKE
IT COMFORTABLE FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO REPORT INCIDENTS OF
HATE CRIMES YOU KNOW TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THAT THOSE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED OR NOT ADD FEAR OF
BEING DEPORTED THEY CAN THEY
CAN MAKE THESE REPORTS- IN IN A
SAFE MANNER WELL WE HAVE MANY-
THE- BILLS COMING FORWARD MANY
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS- BEING PART.
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD BUT- WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT- WE WOULD ASK
OF. THAT YOU REMEMBER THIS
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MR LOW YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
WE'RE DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
DIALOGUE. THE IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE ABOUT RACE THAT HOW WE
SHARE POWER THIS IS A
DELIBERATIVE BODY. AND IF WE
CAN'T EVEN HAVE IT AMONGST
OURSELVES HOW DO WE EXPECT OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR HOMES TO
BE SPEAKING TO EACH OTHER.
TALKING THROUGH EACH OTHER AT
EACH OTHER NOT WITH EACH OTHER.
THAT'S TO MY COLLEAGUE THAT.
WAVING ENQUIRING ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF SCAPEGOATING. THE
DEFINITION OF THAT OF BLAMING
SOMEONE. OR SOME GROUP FOR
EXPEDIENCY- WE'VE HEARD THAT
EARLIER TODAY SO AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE RECOGNITION OF A TRI
CITIES THAT WE CURRENTLY SEE.
IT GOES BEYOND JUST SIMPLY
VOTING I ON A RESOLUTION. THIS
REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
MAKING SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
TACKLING THESE ISSUES. IF NOT
US THEN WHO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. YEAH MISTER LOWE WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MISTER LOS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS CARPOOL OVERALL. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON TO
HR TWENTY THREE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON HR TWENTY THREE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK. WELL
CLOSER RATHER SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED. AND WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A BILL ON CALL.
AT THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
BUT I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU THE
QUORUM CALL HAS NOT BEEN LIFTED
QUORUM CALL. IS IN PLACE. THE
BILL REMAINS ON CALL WE ARE
MOVING TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AND ASK
THAT YOU GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES AT
THIS TIME. WHO WILL BE A
TURNING IN THE MEMORY. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. I RISE
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF ROBERT
WILLIAM AGEE A LOVED AND
RESPECTED NEIGHBOR AND A FRIEND
TO THE CITY OF DAVIS. ROBERT AG
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY TWENTY
TEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY. BOB
LIVED A LIFE THAT LOOKED. EVER
OUTWARD IN CARE AND SERVICE TO
OTHERS AND ALSO EVER IN WORDS
SEEKING GROWTH AND CHANGE
WITHIN HIMSELF. BOBBY WAS BORN
IN SOUTH GATE CALIFORNIA ON
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE AND WAS RAISED IN
ARCADIA. HE SPENT HIS CHILDHOOD
NINETEEN FIFTIES TO LOS ANGELES
WITH HIS BROTHER TOM AT HIS
SIDE FAILING CAMPING PLAYING
BASEBALL. WITH THE NEIGHBORHOOD
KIDS AND EARNING BADGES THROUGH
VOICE SCALED. HIS FATHER FULLER
PASSED ON TO HIM BOTH A SERIOUS
OF PURPOSE AND A LIFELONG DEAL
PERMIT CAMAC ELECTRON TINKERING.
HIS MOTHER ADA CHAU HIM WHAT IT
MEANT TO HIM ONCE. AND ADVOCATE
PUBLIC. AS A YOUNG ADULT BOB
SOUTHERN CAL FOR YOU URKE
EARNING HIS UNDER. DEGREE AND
GRADUATE DEGREES IN BOTH
BUSINESS AND EDUCATION- CAL BOB
ALSO MET AND FELL IN LOVE WITH
JANET SLOAN. BOB AND JAN
MARRIED AND MOVED TO DAVIS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHERE
THEY RAISED THEIR SON
CHRISTOPHER AND DAUGHTERS MEGAN
AND BROUGHT. THAT YEAR BOB ALSO
BEGIN THE TWO DECADE CAREER AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IS INTEGRITY AND
WORK ETHIC MADE HIM A WORTHY
CHAMPION OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS BOB
EVENTUALLY ROSE TO THE POSITION
OF CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT.
BOB CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE LED HIM TO THE
POSITIONS WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER ON EDUCATION AND THE
ECONOMY AND THE UC DAVIS BUDGET
TEAM. HE VOLUNTEERED THE DAVIS
ROTARY CLUB IN RETURN
REBUILDING TOGETHER AND SERVED
AS THE PRESIDENT THE ACADEMICS
WITHOUT BORDERS USA INSURE
DAVIS'S BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. THE
FAMILY BOB AND JAN CREATED
TOGETHER WAS GREATEST SOURCE OF
PRIDE. THEIR DAILY LIVES FILLED
WITH HOMEWORK AND SCIENCE
EXPERIMENTS AT THE KITCHEN
TABLE UNTIL THEY COULD ESCAPE
ON SMALL ADVENTURES A SEEMINGLY
NEVER ENDING CATALOG OF
CAMPFIRE SONGS. EXPLORING THE
OLD HAUNTS OF LOS ANGELES OR
SCALING THE BACKSIDE OF HEALTH
DOME. BOB LOVE RECOUNTING THESE.
WITH PLENTY OF EMBELLISHMENTS.
TO FRIENDS AND STRANGERS ALIKE.
IN MOST RECENT YEARS BOB BECAME
GRAMPA HOME BOMB AND BARBARA
TWO SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN ONCE
AGAIN BARBARA SINGING FONG
SPINNING YARNS BUILDING TOYS
AND FURNITURE REPRISING HIS
ROLE AS THE ALL IN ONE MATH
SCIENCE MUSIC TEACHER. BOB IS
GENEROUS SPIRIT EARNED HIM MANY
FRIENDS HE HAD AN EASY LAUGH
AND ISIS SMILED. WHAT WAS
GENERALLY EAGER TO LISTEN TO
OTHERS. ALWAYS BELIEVED IT'S
SOMETHING TO LEARN FROM THOSE
AROUND HIM. A QUALITY INTO
SHORT SUPPLY IN TODAY'S WORLD.
BOB WILL BE MISSED BY HIS
FAMILY THE DAVIS COMMUNITY AND
ALL THOSE LIVES HE TOUCHED IT'S
PAST SEVENTY FIVE YEARS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ARE. RISE SADLY TO
**** BODY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF ROSY L. BUTLER I CALLED HER
GRANNY. SHE WAS BORN ON JULY
TWENTY SIXTH NINETEEN FORTY IN
SHREVEPORT LOUISIANA AND WAS
ONE OF SEVEN CHILDREN. GRANNY
OF BETTER KNOWN AS MS IS ROSY
L. BUTLER ATTENDED LOUISIANA
SCHOOL SYSTEMS FOR MOST OF HER
EDUCATIONAL CAREER IN NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN SHE MET THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE JOHN L. BUTLER. AND
HAD TWO BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN ONE
SON AND ONE DAUGHTER. MRS
BUTLER JOINED THE WORK FORCE
WHERE SHE WORKED AT MATTEL TOYS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS UNTIL SHE
RETIRED. ROSIE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE SWEET HOUR OF PRAYER CHURCH
WHERE SHE TOOK HER ENTIRE
FAMILY EVERY SUNDAY TO CHURCH%
SHE WAS A FAITHFUL MEMBER UNTIL
HER GRANDSON. COUNCILMAN AND
THE BISHOP JAWAN HILTON STARTED
HIS OWN CHURCH AND THE HOLY
SPIRIT LED HER TO GO IN SUPPORT
HER GRANDSON. THE COUNCIL
MEMBER OF THE CITY OF CARSON.
BUT THIRTEEN YEAR LONG YEARS
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE CITY ON
THE HILL CHURCH IN CARSON. IS
WAS KNOWN FOR ALWAYS HAVING A
SMILE ON HER FACE A WORD OF
ENCOURAGEMENT PRAISE ON HER
LIPS AND A DANCE IN HER FEET.
GRANNY BUBBLER REMINDS ME OF MY
OWN GRANDMOTHER ALWAYS PRAYING
FOR NOT ONLY OF THOSE SHE KNEW
BUT SHE PRAYED FOR OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE GRANNY WAS THERE
PRAYING AND LIFTING THEM UP IN
PRAYER. YOU SEE GRANNY KNEW HOW
TO PRAY.MEMBERS I ASKED BODY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF SOMEONE
WHO ARE CALLED GRANNY BUT OUR
NAME IS MS IS ROSY L. BUTLER.
THANK IMAGE CAPTION. MS
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
AUSTEDO TINO ARE MEANT THAT A
RANCHO SANTA FE. DO YOU KNOW
PASS AWAY LAST MONTH AFTER
WATCHING HIS BUT BELOVED KANSAS
CITY CHIEFS WHEN THE RIGHT TO
PLAY IN THE SUPER BOWL AFTER
BEING CROWNED AFC CHAMPIONS.
HIS LOVE FOR THE CHIEFS CAME
FROM HIS UPBRINGING IN MUNCIE
KANSAS. DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT
WIDER IN TRACK AND IMPROPER. I
TURNER HIGH. AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
TO FOLLOWED HIS FATHER FIRST BY
LISTING IN THE BOROUGH. HE WAS
AWARDED THE TWO. SERVICE MEDAL
AND WAS HONORABLY DISCHARGED
WITH THE RANK OF SERGEANT.
AFTER THE MARINES HE WENT TO
COLLEGE IN LA. IN COLLEGE HE
MET HIS FUTURE WIFE NORA AN
EXCHANGE STUDENT FROM VENEZUELA.
TINO NORRIS CAREER TOOK THEM
AROUND THE COUNTRY YOU KNOW
WORKED FOR THE OIL IN FILM
INDUSTRY ONE NOR WORKED IN
BANKING. WHILE WORKING TO NO
ONE BACK TO SCHOOL AND EARNED
HIS MBA AS WELL AS PHD IN
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESSES. THEIR
CAREERS TOOK TO MANY PLACES BUT
HOME WAS ALWAYS CALIFORNIA.
UPON RETIREMENT YOU KNOW NOR
RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TINA WROTE A
BIOGRAPHY OF THE HOSPITAL
SCHOOL THAT TREATS HIS FAMILY'S
ROOTS TO MEXICO DURING THE TIME
A BUNCH OF VIA. IN ADDITION TO
THE CHEFS TINA WHAT STORE
CLASS CARS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED FIFTY THREE BEL AIR.
HE- LED T. AND LOVED VOLLAND
FOR SEVERAL. EDUCATION
ORGANIZATIONS. IN JANUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE HE WAS
HOSPITALIZED WITH AN INFECTION
AND LATER CONTRACTED COVE IN
NINETEEN. HE WAS ABLE TO RETURN
HOME BUT LATER PASSED AWAY IN
HIS SLEEP DUE TO COMPLICATIONS
FROM COVER NINETEEN AFTER
WATCHING THE AFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME. DO KNOW I MANTHA WAS
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE NORA HIS
CHILDREN ONE AND CHRIS HIS
SIBLINGS MANUEL FROM THE LOBBY.
BEFORE HE'LL FILL IN RIVER. AND
SEVERAL BRANCHES AND
GRANDCHILDREN. HI I THE
ASSEMBLY DRE. TODAY IN MEMORY
OF BOSTON. CHINO I'M. AB AS A
MR GARCIA IN THE OF THE CHAIN
YOUR ALL RIGHT ON THIS TO DRUM
AND- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WANT TO SIGNALED THE CAR.
PROMISES PAID. MR PASTI
TIANANMEN. HIS FAMILY YEAH
DOUBLE ONCE OR- MEMBERS OF OUR
DISTRICT THE CIVIC BEING.
COMMUNITY INDIVIDUALS AND
THOUGHT THEY I WOULD ALSO
TRYING AND JUST IGNORE THE
COUNTRY OF IN ORDER TO OUR
COUNTRY TO OUR STATE AND- AS
FAMILIES CONTRIBUTIONS WORKING
AS WAS ALREADY MENTIONED. A
ARMED SERVICES VETERAN
DISTINGUISHED SCHOLAR. AUTHOR
AND CERTAINLY A MAN WHO WAS
DEDICATED TO HIS FAMILY- IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I'D BE REMISS IF I
AM. ALSO JUST SAY THANK YOU- TO
THEM THIS FAMILY AND THAT WE
ASKED WE TURNED IN HIS LOVING
MEMORY- AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR GARCIA AND YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
GERMAN THE MEMORY DISBURSING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. THE RISE TODAY THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
SINGLE PLOT THAT. HE LONGTIME
ACTIVIST BUSINESS MEMBER ANY
FOR TO MANY THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. INCLUDING SO YOUR BLOOD
THAT WAS BORN. AND YOU
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
TO EZEKIEL PLOT THAT AND MAYBE
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT LOPEZ IN
THE TRUCK ON MAKING. AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY. HE IMMIGRATED TO THE
COACH VALLEY. UPON ARRIVAL HE
WORKED AS A LANDSCAPER
DISHWASHER A WAITER AND
BARTENDER. DURING BY THE GOAL
OF CREATING A BETTER LIFE FOR
HIM AND HIS FAMILY. PERSONALLY
ON ROLLED AT THE COLLEGE OF THE
DESERT. OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. HE BEGAN TO GET
INVOLVED IN STUDENT LIFE. AND
WHILE THERE TOOK UPON HIMSELF
THE INTERESTS OF STUDENT BODY
LEADERSHIP. AND DECIDED TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE SCHOOL
BECOMING THE FIRST PERSON OF
MEXICAN DESCENT TO HOLD THE
POSITION AT THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND REALLY A BIG DEAL
FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AT THAT TIME. THIS
EXPERIENCE MOTIVATED RESILIENT
TO HELP HIS COMMUNITY. THE GAIN
EXPERIENCE WITH A LOCAL BROKER
ASSEMBLY OPEN HIS OWN BUSINESS
I ALWAYS HAD THAT
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT. SERVICE
LEO PLOT THE INSURANCE
SERVICES- WITH THE GOAL OF
HELPING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THIS BUSINESS QUICKLY EXPANDED
AND BECAME A TRUSTED LOCATION
FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO GET
HELP WITH A VARIETY OF ISSUES.
C. IN DEMAND FOR SYSTEMS WITH
TRANSLATION ISSUES WITH
IMMIGRATION AND CITIZENSHIP.
WITH A LITTLE FOUNDED THE CLUB
MEETS OUR PANEL FONG. THIS CLUB
HELD RESIDENTS APPLY FOR LEGAL
RESIDENCY AND CITIZENSHIP FOR
FREE. FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
MANY MANY YEARS. PERSONALLY
WENT ON TO START THE LOCAL
CHAPTER OF THE COUNCIL OF
MEXICAN FEDERATIONS IN NORTH
AMERICA ALSO KNOWN AS COFFIN.
THEIR MISSION IS TO EMPOWER
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES TO FULL
PARTICIPATION IN THE SOCIAL
POLITICAL ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
LIFE IN THE UNITED STATES AND I
WAS VERY PROUD. THAT THEIR
OFFICE IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WAS HOUSED. AT CITY HALL THERE
IN THE CITY PATELLA WHILE I WAS
MAYOR. SORGEN STATION WAS ALSO
INSTRUMENTAL IN DEVELOPING A
LASTING RELATIONSHIP. WITH THE
MEXICAN CONSULATE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY THAT TODAY TO HAVE A
VERY VERY PROMINENT ROLE. AND
HAVE NOW AN OFFICE IN CITY HALL
IN THE CITY OF COACHELLA.
BEYOND ALL THIS RESOLUTION WITH
A STRONG PROPONENT OF THE ARTS.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN BRINGING
NUMEROUS MUSICAL ENTERTAINMENT
ACTS OF THE COACH OF ALLEY. THE
ORGANIZED. IN NEXUS WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FROM MICHOACAN.
DIRECTLY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITY MAKING SURE THAT AND
THEY WEREN'T JUST ENTERTAINMENT
EVENTS BUT THAT THEY ALSO
BECOME RESOURCE FAIRS. TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY. AT
ONE OF THESE EVENTS HE ACTUALLY
HAD IN MICHOACAN. CREATED THE
WORLD'S LARGEST MORE GUY KEPT
THEIR- THOSE OF YOU KNOW IT
WON'T GO AHEAD IS THAT. ONE
THING WE USED TO MAKE SALSA.
ANY HAD THE LARGE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST MORE GO AHEAD THE ON
DISPLAY AT ONE OF THESE EVENTS.
THAT KIND A LOT OF PEOPLE'S
ATTENTION I JUST IMAGINE THE
LARGEST ONE TO HIT THE EVER
MADE. THAT WAS- SOMETHING TO
REMEMBER. COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN PAYING HOMAGE IN
HONORING ROUGHLY ABOUT THE- FOR
HIS LOVE. DEDICATION AND
ADVOCACY. IT'S COMMUNITY. A
CHAMPION FOR THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. WHO WE LOST ON DECEMBER
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY K.
SIERRA LEONE HAS- BUT OUT OF
ARMENIA CAN ASSIST DONGLE. FOR
INTERNET. GETTY ABOUT IT AND MY
YOU A MEAL THE MONEY THAT THAT
I. WHEN SONIC A MODEL SYSTEM IN
YOUR RESTAURANT THE PERSON. IN
PAIN KNOW UNDERSTOODTHAT. YOU
MUST CANNELLA PERFORMANCE. YEAH
MORE. I SAID OF SIEMPRE AND SO
EN OF WHAT I YOU THAT I
DISPATCH ON US. ELOUISE SAUCE
WOULD BE MY HOME. HE ESTAMOS
MUITO SEAL SUPPORT OF IT. WELL
A SADDAM FORKLIFT IN PROPONENT.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A BILL THE
REMAINS ON CALL THIS WILL BE
RECESSED UNDER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER AND I'M ASKING THAT YOU
RETURNED PROMPTLY TO THE FLOOR
AT FOUR PM. PLEASE RETURN
PROMPTLY AT FOUR PM. TO THE
GREEN CARPET. YOU MAY GO TO
YOUR OFFICES PLEASE DO NOT
LEAVE THE BUILDING MEMBERS AND
RETURNED PROMPTLY AT FOUR THIS
IS RECESSED UNDER CALL.
NUMBER
SIX FOUR PM RECESSES OVER
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR. AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
MEMBERS
PLEASE RETURN THE FOR. WE HAVE
A BILL ON CALL.
PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR. PLEASE RETURN TO
THE.
FOR MEMBERS I HAVE A BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR TODAY HAS
BEEN CANCELED THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. HEARING HAS BEEN
CANCELED. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL. WE HAVE SAID THE MEMBERS
RETURN OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THAT COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
TO WILL BE MEETING A PART OF
GERMAN BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE TO
WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT. IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
TO. M. PLEASE NOTE THAT THE
BILL INTRODUCTION DEADLINE IS
THIS FRIDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
AT FIVE PM THE BUDGET THE BILL
INTRODUCTION DEADLINE IS FRIDAY.
AT FIVE PM. WE HAVE ONE ITEM I
CALL. I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON SB TWENTY NINE THE
CORPORAL POSTS. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSER ROLE. TELL YOU
ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
FOURTEEN ON THE URGENCY. HIGHS
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FOURTEEN ON
THE MEASURE. THE BILL PASSES
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN OUR MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. BRIEFLY
MEMBERS SESSION SCHEDULE
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH FLOOR
SESSIONS AT NINE AM SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MR WARD MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS. AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH. AT NINE AM
IN THE QUORUM CALL THIS FINALLY
LIFTED.